हेलो एवरीवन एंड फर्स्ट ऑफ ऑल वेरी गुड
इवनिंग टू ऑल। सबको मेरी आवाज सुनाई दे
रही है?
सबको मेरी आवाज सुनाई दे रही है?
हेलो आ रही है ना सबको मेरी आवाज?
ओके थैंक यू। तो
वेरी गुड इवनिंग। वेरी गुड इवनिंग। और जो
आप पूछ रहे थे क्या नाम है? कितने टॉपिक
बचे हुए हैं? यह अभी कोर्स हाफ भी नहीं
आया। सच बोलूं तो मैं आपको कितना कुछ
पढ़ाने वाला हूं। यू कैन नॉट इमेजिन
सोचिए। ठीक है? मैं इतनी चीजें पढ़ाने
वाला हूं आप लोगों को कि बहुत कुछ पढ़ाने
वाला हूं। यह जस्ट अभी तक मैं आपको
फंडामेंटल ही क्लियर कर रहा हूं। आपको
फंडामेंटल या जो आपको बिगिनियर बोल सकते
हैं। बिगिनियर प्लस प्लस बोल सकते हैं।
सिर्फ वही क्लियर कर रहा हूं। अभी तक तो
मैंने आपका एक भी एडवांस पार्ट क्लियर
नहीं किया। कि अभी तक मैंने एडवांस पढ़ाया
ही नहीं है आप लोगों को।
तो 1 मिनट का समय लेते हैं। स्टूडेंट को
आने देते हैं। तो देखते हैं कितने
स्टूडेंट्स अभी आए हैं। कितने और आने वाले
हैं।
तो सबसे पहले मुझे बताओ कि आप लोग कैसे
हो? काफी टाइम बाद हम क्लास ले रहे हैं।
तो कैसे हो आप लोग?
सब लोग बढ़िया हो?
बिल्कुल बढ़िया।
गुड।
ओके। अच्छी बात है। मैं भी अगर आप लोग
बढ़िया हो तो मैं भी बढ़िया हूं। बिल्कुल।
जैसे आप वैसे मैं कोई इशू नहीं है। तो
चलिए हम सेशन को स्टार्ट करते हैं। फिर
ज्यादा टाइम वेस्ट नहीं करेंगे आप लोगों
का। तो चलिए आज का जो टॉपिक है काफी
इंटरेस्टिंग टॉपिक है और आज का और नेक्स्ट
टॉपिक भी काफी इंटरेस्टिंग रहेगा और
एडवांस टॉपिक लाइक
इट इज अ सरप्राइज डिपेंड्स ऑन यू गाइस आप
लोगों का रिस्पांस क्या है दैट इज फाइन तो
चलिए
नाउ अभी हम चलते हैं पहले अपनी स्लाइड पर
हम टॉपिक पढ़ते हैं तो आज का जो हमारा
टॉपिक है जो हमारा जो सेक्शन है वो वो है
डंपिंग िंग एंड क्रैकिंग हैस के ऊपर है।
तो हम दोनों ही केस में पढ़ेंगे। अभी
Windows पे काम कर रहे हैं। लinक्स के भी
केस में हम पढ़ने वाले हैं। तो जैसा कि
मैं आपको रिमाइंड करवा देता हूं कि हमने
स्टेप वन में लोकल एलुमिशन के बारे में
पढ़ा था। स्टेप टू हम पढ़ चुके हैं। फाइल
को कैसे ट्रांसफर करना है, सेल को कैसे
अपग्रेड करना है, यह भी स्टेप थ्री हम पढ़
चुके हैं। पोस्ट एक्सप्लइटेशन का।
प्रिविलेज एस्केलेशन भी हम अच्छे से पढ़
चुके हैं और आने वाले टाइम में भी पढ़ने
वाले हैं। अभी तक तो मैं सिर्फ आपको बता
रहा हूं कि प्रिविलेज एस्केलेशन होता कैसे
है? कैसे-कैसे आप अप्रोच कर सकते हो
प्रिविलेज एस्केलेशन के लिए। जस्ट दीज़ आर
द बिगिनियर। बस आपको बता रहा हूं ना कि
आपकी बिगिनियर लेवल की चीजें अभी तक
क्लियर कर रहा हूं कि यह टेक्निक होती
क्या है और इससे हमें फायदा क्या होता है
शायद। स्टेप फाइव आपका पर्सिस्टेंस एक्सेस
मेंटेन करना। करना अभी तक मैंने सिखाया
नहीं है। इस पे भी एक दो क्लासेस मैं आपको
एज इन डेमोंस्ट्रेशन प्रैक्टिकल प्लस
थ्योरेटिकल लेने वाला हूं। तो आज का जो
हमारा टॉपिक है स्टेप सिक्स डंपिंग एंड
क्रैकिंग हैसेसिस उस पर हम डिस्कस करने
वाले हैं और यह काफीेंट होता है क्योंकि
अगर आपको आपका एक्सेस पर्सिस्टेंटली
मेंटेन करना है तो दिस इज़ आल्सो वेरी
वेरीेंट और कई बार सिस्टम की मिस
कॉन्फ़िगरेशन की वजह से आपको यह हैस या जो
पासवर्ड्स हैं आपको सिस्टम में देखने को
मिल जाते हैं। पिवेटिंग और क्लियरिंग और
ट्रैक्स एक-एक सेशन इनका भी करवाएंगे हाई
ओवरव्यू पर उसके बाद देखते हैं कि कितना
डिटेल्स जाना है नहीं जाना है वह हम बाद
में बात करेंगे। तो चलिए फिर हम स्टार्ट
करते हैं।
तो आज का जो हमारा टॉपिक रहेगा वो है आपका
क्रेडेंशियल डंपिंग विंडोज ऑपरेटिंग
सिस्टम।
आज हम पता चल गया कि आज का कौन सा टॉपिक
है हमारा क्रेडेंशियल डंपिंग Windows
ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम
आज हम क्रेडेंशियल डंपिंग वाले सेक्शन में
डिस्कस करेंगे कि Windows के क्रेडेंशियल
के बारे में स्पेशली जो Windows के
क्रेडेंशियल्स है सिर्फ उसी के बारे में
डिस्कस करने वाले हैं। तो सबसे पहले हम ये
समझेंगे कि Windows सिस्टम पर जो भी
क्रेडेंशियल जो पासवर्ड हैज़ कहां पर स्टोर
होते हैं सबसे पहले और उनका क्या मतलब है
और इसकी शुरुआत करने के लिए
सबसे पहले यह समझना जरूरी है कि हैज़ होते
क्या हैं? और Windows उन्हें किस जगह पर
स्टोर करता है। ओके? Windows उन्हें किस
जगह पर स्टोर करता है? यह चीजें आपको
पता होनी चाहिए। तो सबसे पहले स्टार्ट
करते हैं Windows पासवर्ड हैस के बारे
में। द Windows ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम स्टोर्स
हैज़ यूजर अकाउंट पासवर्ड्स लोकली इन द सेम
डेटाबेस। सेम मतलब सिक्योरिटी अकाउंट
मैनेजर। जो Windows ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम्स है
जो किसी भी यूज़र्स के जो पासवर्ड्स हैं
उन उनके जो हैश वैल्यू है उसको सेम
डेटाबेस के अंदर स्टोर करता है। सेम
डेटाबेस का मतलब वी कैन से दैट Windows
में वो फाइल या वो रजिस्ट्री एरिया जहां
पर यह है वैल्यू स्टोर होती है। अभी
हैशिंग क्या होता है? हैशिंग इज़ द प्रोसेस
ऑफ़ कन्वर्टिंग ए पीस ऑफ़ डेटा इंटू अनदर
वैल्यू। एंड ए हैशिंग फंक्शन और एल्गोरिदम
इज यूज्ड टू जनरेट द न्यू वैल्यू। द
रिजल्ट ऑफ ए हैिंग एल्गोरिदम इज नोन एज ए
हैश और हैश वैल्यू।
बेसिकली हैशिंग एक मैथमेटिकल प्रोसेस है।
जहां जो ओरिजिनल डेटा है ओरिजिनल डेटा
लाइक आपके जो पासवर्ड्स हैं उनको एक
फिक्स्ड लेंथ एक जो फिक्स्ड लेंथ वैल्यू
है उसमें कन्वर्ट किया जाता है। और इस
कन्वर्जन के लिए कुछ स्पेसिफिक एल्गोरिदम
यूज़ किए जाते हैं। जैसे कि आपकी एमडी5
एमडी4 या सा वन सा 256 सा 512 जो सा की
फैमिली की जो एल्गोरिदम्स है उनका या हम
विंडोज के केस में बात करें एंटी#श लॉजिक
अब ये एल्गोरिदम क्या करती है यह
एल्गोरिदम डिसाइड करती है कि आपको किस
टाइप का आउटपुट मिलेगा बेस्ड ऑन योर इनपुट
और जो भी वैल्यू
इन एल्गोरिदम से आपको आउटपुट में देखने को
मिलती है। उसको हम बोलते हैं#श।
उस वैल्यू को हम क्या बोलते हैं? हैश
वैल्यू।
और यह वैल्यू इरिवर्स इरिवर्सिबल
रिप्रेजेंटेशन है आपके ओरिजिनल डेटा की।
जो भी ये वैल्यू्यूज हैं आपका जो ओरिजिनल
डेटा है उसकी इररिवर्सिबल रिप्रेजेंटेशन
होती है।
तो अभी बात करें मॉडर्न Windows ऑपरेटिंग
सिस्टम की। जो मॉडर्न Windows ऑपरेटिंग
सिस्टम पर जो लोकल स्टोरेज है पासवर्ड को
अगर आपको लोकली स्टोर करना है वो काफी
रिस्की माना जाता है। क्यों? क्योंकि अगर
अटैकर्स को उस मशीन पर लोकल एक्सेस मिल
गया तो वह उन#श वैल्यू का क्या कर सकता
है? किसी डिफरेंट अटैक्स के लिए ट्राई कर
सकता है। वह उन हैश वैल्यू को क्या कर
सकता है? कोई भी डिफरेंट अटैक्स है उसके
लिए ट्राई कर सकता है। इसलिए मशीनंस पर
लोकल पासवर्ड को हैंडल करना काफी सेंसिटिव
माना जाता है। सन 2000 जो अर्ली 200 था या
हम बात करें सन 2000 के बाद क्या हुआ कि
जो
सिक्योरिटी प्रैक्टिससेस थी उनको काफी
इवॉल्व किया गया। पुरानी वीक हैसिंग और
इंक्रिप्शन स्कीम्स को रिप्लेस और डिसेबल
किया गया। आप पूछोगे क्यों? क्योंकि उनको
बहुत ही आसानी से क्रैक किया जा सकता था
और इसी वजह से Windows ने भी अपनी हैशिंग
अप्रोचेस को अपडेट किया या हम बोल सकते
हैं अपग्रेड किया। तो अब अब नाउ अ डेज आज
के सिनेरियो में होता क्या है? अब होता
क्या है कि जब भी कोई भी यूजर Windows के
अंदर अकाउंट क्रिएट करता है और उस अपना
पासवर्ड एंटर करता है तो उस पासवर्ड को
प्लेन टेक्स्ट में स्टोर नहीं किया जाता।
सिस्टम उस पासवर्ड को एक हैश की फॉर्म में
स्टोर करता है। और ऑथेंटिकेशन टाइम पर
क्या होता है? ऑथेंटिकेशन टाइम पर यूज़र्स
के यूजर ने जो भी पासवर्ड एंटर किया है उस
पासवर्ड को हैश में कन्वर्ट करके और जो
हैश की फॉर्म में पासवर्ड स्टोर किया गया
है उसके साथ कंपेयर किया जाता है और जब वह
पासवर्ड मैच हो जाता है तो आपको एक्सेस
मिल जाता है अदरवाइज आपको एक्सेस नहीं
मिलता। ऑथेंटिकेशन एंड वेरिफिकेशन ऑफ यूजर
क्रेडेंशियल्स इज फैसिलिटेटेड बाय द लोकल
सिक्योरिटी अथॉरिटी।
अब यह सब मैनेज किया जाता है जो भी
ऑथेंटिकेशंस है या जो भी वेरिफिकेशंस है
उस पासवर्ड्स का वह सब मैनेज किया जाता है
आपकी एक प्रोसेस के द्वारा। उस प्रोसेस का
नाम है लोकल सिक्योरिटी अथॉरिटी एलएसए
प्रोसेस। यह प्रोसेस रिस्पांसिबल है आपके
सिक्योरिटी टोकंस के लिए, क्रेडेंशियल्स
वेरिफिकेशंस के लिए या आपके
पासवर्ड से रिलेटेड जो भी पॉलिसीज है उनको
इनफोर्स करने के लिए। इन सबके लिए
रिस्पांसिबल यही प्रोसेस है। एंड Windows
वर्जन अप टू Windows सर्वर 2003
यूटिलाइज टू डिफरेंट टाइप्स ऑफ हैशेस।
कि Windows सर्वर 2003 तक दो टाइप के
हैशेस का यूज़ किया जाता था। एक था एलएम#श
दूसरा होता था एंटी एलएम। उसके बाद क्या
हुआ कि Windows ने एलएम#श को यूज़ करना बंद
कर दिया। और अभी एंटी एलएम#श यूज़ किया
जाता है। कब से? Windows Vist के बाद। जो
Windows histा थी वो लास्ट विंड ऑपरेटिंग
सिस्टम का वर्जन था जिसमें एलम हैसिंग का
यूज़ किया जाता था। उसके बाद से एंटी एलम
हैस का यूज़ किया जाता है। तो अभी हम सेम
डेटाबेस के बारे में समझते हैं कि व्हाट
इज सेम डेटाबेस?
सेम सिक्योरिटी अकाउंट मैनेजर इज ए
डेटाबेस फाइल दैट इज रिस्पांसिबल फॉर
मैनेजिंग यूजर अकाउंट एंड पासवर्ड्स ऑन
Windows। ऑल यूजर अकाउंट पासवर्ड स्टर्ड
इन द सेम डेटाबेस आर हैश बाय डिफॉल्ट
सेम एक लोकल डेटाबेस फाइल है जो Windows
के
जो भी यूजर अकाउंट्स हैं और उनसे रिलेटेड
जो भी पासवर्ड्स हैं उनको मैनेज करता है।
जैसे यूजरनेम अकाउंट की प्रॉपर्टीज
पासवर्ड रिलेटेड डेटा जो भी ऑपरेटिंग
सिस्टम को जरूरत है जिनका मैं बताया कि
अकाउंट की प्रॉपर्टीज हो गई या यूजरनेम वो
यहीं पर स्टोर होती है। किसके अंदर? सेम
डेटाबेस के अंदर। दी सेम डेटाबेस फाइल कैन
नॉट बी कॉपीड व्हाइल द ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम इज
रनिंग। जब आपका ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम रन करता
है, तो सेम डेटाबेस फाइल को कॉपी नहीं
किया जा सकता। सो, दिस इज़ द सिक्योरिटी
फीचर्स दैट वाज़ इंप्लीमेंटेड बाय द
Windows। यह सिक्योरिटी फीचर्स आपके
Windows ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम के द्वारा
इंप्लीमेंट किया गया है। इफ समवन गॉट
एक्सेस टू द सेम डेटाबेस व्हाइल द सिस्टम
वाज रनिंग देन दे वुड एसेंशियली बी एबल टू
डंप द कंटेंट्स ऑफ द सेम डेटाबेस। अगर कोई
भी यूजर या कोई भी अटैकर्स, कोई भी
पेंटेस्टर्स अगर
सेम डेटाबेस को एक्सेस कर लेता है। खास
करके जब सिस्टम रनिंग कंडीशन में है तो वह
बहुत ही आसानी से सेम डेटाबेस के अंदर जो
भी कंटेंट है उसको डंप कर सकता है। बट इट
इज़ नॉट पॉसिबल। द Windows एंटी कर्नल कीप
द सेम डेटाबेस फाइल लॉक्ड एंड एज ए रिजल्ट
अटैकर्स टिपिकली यूटिलाइज़ इन मेमोरी
टेक्निक्स एंड टूल्स टू डंप सेम हैज़ फ्रॉम
द एल्स प्रोसेस। अब होता क्या है कि जो
Windows एंटी कर्नल है वही इस सेम डेटाबेस
फाइल को क्या करता है? सेफ कस्टडी में
रखता है। उसको लॉक करके रखता है। लेकिन
अटैकर्स क्या है? इतने स्मार्ट है।
अटैकर्स क्या करते हैं? इन मेमोरी
टेक्निक्स का यूज़ करते हैं। और उन टूल्स
का यूज़ करते हैं जो एलसेस प्रोसेस से डेटा
को डंप कर सकते हैं। अब कौन सा टूल इसका
ज्यादा यूज़ किया जाता है? मिमीड्स आपने
सुना होगा। उस टूल का यूज़ किया जाता है।
तो आज की क्लास में तो हम टूल्स के बारे
में नहीं पढ़ने वाले। बट नेक्स्ट क्लास में
हम मिमी कैच टूल्स के बारे में जरूर पढ़ने
वाले हैं। तो इन मॉडर्न वर्जन ऑफ Windows
द सेम डेटाबेस इज इंक्रिप्टेड विद सिसकी।
और एक और चीज आप लोगों के लिए इंपॉर्टेंट
यह है कि एलिवेटेड एंड एडमिनिस्ट्रेटिव
प्लेजेस आर रिक्वायर्ड इन ऑर्डर टू एक्सेस
एंड इंटैक्ट विद द एलसेस प्रोसेस। अभी अगर
आपको एलसेस प्रोसेस के साथ इंटैक्ट करना
है या आपको एलएसएस जो सिक्योरिटी प्रोसेस
है और जो एलsएस है जो आपके ऑथेंटिकेशन के
लिए रिस्पांसिबल है विंडोज के ऊपर अगर
इनके साथ आपको इंटैक्ट करना है तो आपके
पास एडमिन लेवल के प्रलज होने चाहिए
अदरवाइज यू कैन नॉट इंटैक्ट विद एलसास
प्रोसेस ओके तो यह एक कंपलसरी कंडीशंस है
विदाउट एडमिन लेवल प्लेजेस यू कैन नॉट
इंटैक्ट विद
एलएस प्रोसेस बिल्कुल आदित्य पास द हैश
अटैक के बारे में भी हम पढ़ने वाले हैं।
डोंट वरी नेक्स्ट क्लास में पढ़ लेंगे।
इसकी चिंता आप लोग बिल्कुल भी मत कीजिए।
बस आप लोग क्लास पे ध्यान दीजिए। तो इन
मॉडर्न ये मैं आपको एक्सप्लेन कर चुका
हूं। तो यहां तक सबको समझ में आ गया कि
सेम डेटाबेस होता क्या है? ऑल ऑफ यू
क्लियर कि सेम डेटाबेस होता क्या है? सबको
यह चीज क्लियर है? किसी को कोई डाउट है
पूछ सकता है अभी चैट में।
आई विल एक्सप्लेन
दीज़ आर द टू डिफरेंट थिंग्स।
ओके? भी ज्यादा टू डिफरेंट थिंग्स बट एक
साथ काम करते हैं ये और मैं एक बार आपको
एक्सप्लेन कर चुका हूं ये। तो चलिए सबसे
पहले हम बात करते हैं एलन एलएम के बारे
में। एलएम का फुल फॉर्म है लेन मैनेजर
जिसे शॉर्ट में हम बोलते हैं एलएम। ओके?
जिसको शॉर्ट में हम क्या बोलते हैं? एलएम।
फुल फॉर्म है लेन मैनेजर।
यह क्या है? यह एक पुराना
पासवर्ड हैचिंग एल्गोरिदम था जिसको
Windows के पुराने वर्जन में यूज़ किया
जाता था। कौन से वर्जन? स्पेशली Windows
NT 4.0 से पहले या 4.0 से पहले। सो एलम इज
अ डिफॉल्ट हैचिंग एल्गोरिदम दैट वाज
इंप्लीमेंटेड इन Windows ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम
प्रीयर टू NT4.0
यानी कि एलम एक डिफॉल्ट हैचिंग एल्गोरिदम
था जो Windows के NT4.0
से पहले के वर्जनंस में इंप्लीमेंट किया
गया था। उस टाइम पर क्या था कि Windows
Windows यूज़र्स के जो भी पासवर्ड्स थे
उनको सिक्योर करने के लिए इसी एल्गोरििदम
का यूज किया जाता था। एंड द प्रोटोकॉल इज
यूज्ड टू हैश यूजर पासवर्ड्स एंड द हैशिंग
प्रोसेस कैन बी ब्रोकन डाउन इनू फॉलोइंग
स्टेप्स। एलएम का काम था यूज़र्स के
पासवर्ड को हैश फॉर्म में कन्वर्ट करना
ताकि सिस्टम पासवर्ड्स को डायरेक्टली
प्लेन टैक्स में स्टोर ना किया जा सके। और
इस प्रोसेस को कुछ स्टेप्स में किया
परफॉर्म किया जाता था कि मतलब इस अगर आपको
किसी भी प्लेन पासवर्ड को अगर हैश में
कन्वर्ट करना है इसके कुछ स्टेप्स होते उन
स्टेप्स में उसको परफॉर्म किया जाता था।
तो एलएम के कौन-कौन से स्टेप्स थे? सबसे
पहला स्टेप था दी पासवर्ड इज़ ब्रोकन इंटू
टू सेवन कररेक्टर्स।
सबसे पहले एल एल्गोरिदम क्या करती थी कि
पासवर्ड को दो पार्ट्स में डिवाइड कर देता
था और हर पार्ट में मैक्सिमम सेवन
कररेक्टर्स होते थे। और अगर आपके पासवर्ड
की लेंथ 14 कररेक्टर्स से कम थी तो क्या
होता था कि जो एलम एल्गोरिदम थी वह अपनी
तरफ से पैडिंग ऐड कर देती थी। मतलब जो
खाली स्पेस को भर देती थी किसी भी रैंडम
कीवर्ड से।
दूसरा क्या है? सेकंड स्टेप क्या था? ऑल
कररेक्टर्स आर देन कन्वर्टेड इनू अपपर
केस। और बाद में क्या होता था कि उन सारे
कररेक्टर्स को अपर केस में कन्वर्ट किया
जा कर दिया जाता था। इसका मतलब यह हुआ कि
एलम आपका केस सेंसिटिव नहीं था। चाहे
पासवर्ड आप किसी भी फॉर्म में कन्वर्ट करो
या किसी भी फॉर्म में एंटर करो। उसकी
फाइनल कन्वर्ज़ क्या होती थी? अपर केस।
मतलब केस सेंसिटिव हुआ ही नहीं।
थर्ड स्टेप क्या था? ईच ट्रंक इज देन
हैड्ड सेपरेटली विद द डीईएस एल्गोरिदम।
उसके बाद आपके पासवर्ड को दो चंक्स में
डिवाइड किया गया सेवन सेवन कररेक्टर्स के।
दोनों को अलग-अलग हैश किया जाता था डीईएस
एल्गोरिदम की हेल्प से और उसके बाद इनको
कंबाइन कर दिया जाता था और आपका जो आउटपुट
आता था वो आपका एलएम हैश आता था। जैसे अब
डायग्राम में शो किया गया है। पासवर्ड पी
@ एस एस डब्ल्यू ओ आर डी 1 2 3 तो सेवन
कररेक्टर्स पी ए एस एस डब्ल्यू आर ये सेवन
कररेक्टर्स कैपिटल अपर केस डी वन टू थ्री
ये अपपर केस अब इसके अंदर टोटल चार ही
कररेक्टर बचे तो बाकी जो तीन बच गए उसमें
पैडिंग ऐड कर दी जाती थी और दोनों को
अलग-अलग डीएस एल्गोरिथ्म के थ्रू हैश
फॉर्म में कन्वर्ट किया जाता था और हैश वन
है टू और दोनों को मिलाकर आपका एलएम हैश
बनता था
अब यह इतना इजी था कि इसको बहुत ही आसानी
से क्या किया जा सकता था?
करेक्ट किया जा सकता था। बिकॉज़ गेस करना
आसान हो गया। पासवर्ड कुछ भी हो लेकिन वो
तो अपपर केस ही होगा। दैट इज व्हाई इट इज़
वेरी वेरीरी इजी टू
अटैक और क्रैक। नाउ एलएम हैसिंग इज जनरली
कंसीडर्ड टू बी अ वीक प्रोटोकॉल एंड कैन
इजीली बी क्रैक एंड प्राइमरी बिकॉज़ द
पासवर्ड हैज़ डज नॉट इंक्लूड साल्ट एंड
क्सक्वेंटली मेकिंग ब्रूट फोर्स एंड रेनबो
टेबल अटैक्स इफेक्टिव अगेंस्ट एलम हैस
एलम हैसिंग एल्ग एल्गोरिदम को अभी के टाइम
में बात करें 2025 या 26 की बात करें तो
बहुत ज्यादा वीक माना जाता है क्योंकि
इसमें में साल्ट का कांसेप्ट बिल्कुल भी
नहीं था। साल्ट का मतलब होता है रैंडम
डाटा ऐड करना किसी एक्स्ट्रा सिक्योरिटी
के लिए। साल्ट ना होने की वजह से क्या
होता था कि जो एलएम हैश था वो काफी आसानी
से रेनबो टेबल्स या जो ब्रूट फ़ोर्स अटैक
थे उनसे क्रैक किया जा सकता था। मतलब कैसे
क्रैक किया जा सकता था कि जो अटैकर्स थे
किसी ने अगर रेनबो टेबल अटैक परफॉर्म किया
है या रेनबो टेबल अटैक के बारे में सुना
भी है तो क्या होता था कि अटैकर्स के पास
ऑलरेडी प्रीम्यूटेड टेबल्स होती थी जिसमें
एलम हैश होते थे और जस्ट क्या करना होता
था कि उनको एक टूल की हेल्प से उस हैश को
कंपेयर करना होता था और अगर कंपेयर करने
के बाद अगर हैश मैश हो जाते थे तो इसका
मतलब वह आपका वैलिड पासवर्ड होता था यह
बहुत ही इजी प्रोसेस थी तो एलम हैज़ क्लियर
क्लियर हो गया कि एलएम क्या होता था आपका?
एवरीवन क्लियर एलएम
एवरीवन इज क्लियर एलएम व्हाट इज एलएम लन
मैनेजर
एवरीवन देखो चैट में आंसर तो सब लोग कर
सकते हो या नहीं कर सकते बताओ
डोंट वरी इसका आज मेरे पास एक
एक्चुअल में एक अच्छा प्रैक्टिकल आप लोगों
के लिए दिखाने के लिए चिंता मत कीजिए एक
सीटीएफ टाइप का है जो मेरे द्वारा बनाया
गया है आप लोगों के लिए उसके बाद नेक्स्ट
भी आपका सीटीएफ बेस ही रहेगा कैसे
क्रैकिंग होती है बट आज का थोड़ा इजी है
बट एक अच्छे सिनेरियो के साथ है डोंट वरी
प्रैक्टिकली है तो अभी हम बात करते हैं
एनटीएलएम की एनटीएलएम इज कलेक्शन ऑफ
ऑथेंटिकेशन प्रोटोकॉल दैट आर यूटिलाइज्ड
इन Windows टू
फैसिलिटेट ऑथेंटिकेशन बिटवीन
कंप्यूटरटर्स। द ऑथेंटिकेशन प्रोसेस
इनवॉल्व्स यूजिंग अ वैलिड यूजरनेम एंड
पासवर्ड टू ऑथेंटिकेट सक्सेसफुली। इसका भी
सेम पर्पस था जिसको हम एंटी#श बोलते हैं।
इसका भी काम क्या है कि पासवर्ड को हैश
फॉर्म में कन्वर्ट करना और उसके बाद क्या
है? उस हैश को कंपेयर किया जाएगा ड्यूरिंग
ऑथेंटिकेशन। फ्रॉम Windows विstा ऑनवर्ड्स
Windows डिसेबल्स एलएम हैिंग एंड यूटिलाइज
एंटीएलम है और Windows विstा के बाद क्या
हुआ कि Windows ने एलएम है को डिसेबल कर
दिया क्योंकि उसको आसानी से क्रैेक किया
जा सकता था और उसके बाद यूटिलाइज किया
जाने लगा एंटीएलम हैंगिंग को व्हेन अ यूजर
अकाउंट इज़ क्रिएटेड इट इज़ इंक्रिप्टेड
यूजिंग द एमडी फॉर हैशिंग एल्गोरिदम उसको
क्या किया जाता है कि एमडी फॉर हैशिंग
एल्गोरिदम की हेल्प से क्या किया जाता है
उसको इंक्रिप्ट कर दिया जाता है व्हाइल द
ओरिजिनल पासवर्ड इज डिस्पोज्ड आउट। उसके
बाद क्या होता है? जो आपका जो ओरिजिनल
पासवर्ड था आपने एंटर किया उसको डिस्पोज
कर दिया गया। मतलब उसको डिलीट कर दिया
गया। अभी
ये भी कई स्टेप इन स्टेप्स में परफॉर्म
किया था। एंटी एलम इंप्रूव्स अपॉन एलम इन
द फॉलोइंग वे। कि अब एंटी एलम कैसे हैशिंग
में कन्वर्ट करता था। इट डज़ नॉट स्प्लिट द
हैश इनू टू चंक्स। यह पहली बात तो आपके
पासवर्ड्स को दो अंक में डिवाइड नहीं करता
था। दूसरा केस सेंसिटिव है। उसमें क्या
था? केस सेंसिटिव नहीं था। दूसरा क्या है
कि इसमें आप सिंबल्स और यूनिकोड
कररेक्टर्स का भी यूज कर सकते हो। हालांकि
उसमें आप यूज़ नहीं कर पाते थे। करते थे
क्योंकि एक ही फॉर्म में कन्वर्ट किया
जाता था। तो इन्हीं कारणों से क्या है? यह
थोड़ा उससे हार्ड हुआ। नेक्स्ट यह इसका
डायग्राम है। यह आपका पासवर्ड है। MD4
एल्गोरिदम के को दे दिया गया। उसके बाद
उसकी फॉर्म एक हैश कन्वर्ट कर दी गई। यह
आपका एंटी एलम हैस बन गया। सबको समझ में
आया कि एंटीएलम हैश होता क्या है? एवरीवन
एंटी एलम हैस होता क्या है?
चलिए अब वह घड़ी आने वाली है जिसके बेस पर
आज हमारा फर्स्ट प्रैक्टिकल
होने वाला है। फर्स्ट प्रैक्टिकल है।
फर्स्ट टेक्निक है सर्चिंग फॉर पासवर्ड्स
इन कॉन्फ़िगरेशन फाइल्स। यह हमारी पहली
टेक्निक है जिसको हम एक्सप्लोर करने वाले
हैं। और इस टेक्निक का मेन गोल है Windows
कॉन्फ़िगरेशन फाइल्स के अंदर स्टोर किए हुए
यूज़र्स नेम और पासवर्ड को ढूंढना और
आइडेंटिफाई करना। अब इंपॉर्टेंट बात यह है
कि यहां पर हम थर्ड पार्टी एप्लीकेशनेशंस
के अंदर जो कॉन्फ़िगरेशन फाइल्स होती है,
उनमें हम पासवर्ड नहीं ढूंढने वाले। हम
स्पेशली Windows की के अंदर जो भी उसकी
खुद की कॉन्फ़िगरेशन फाइल्स है उनको टारगेट
करेंगे। क्यों? क्योंकि इन्हीं में सबसे
ज्यादा सेंसिटिव क्रेडेंशियल्स मिलने के
चांसेस हाई होते हैं। और इस केस में हम
देखने वाले हैं अनअटेंडेड विंडोज सेटअप।
ठीक है? अनअटेंडेड Windows सेटअप। एक
कॉन्फ़िगरेशंस फाइल्स होती है जिसके अंदर
आपको एडमिन पासवर्ड्स या यूजर
क्रेडेंशियल्स देखने को मिलते हैं स्टोर
किए हुए और यह फाइल क्या होती है? इसके
बारे में हम देखने वाले हैं। यह फाइल हम
क्या होते हैं? इसके बारे में हम देखने
वाले हैं। तो, Windows कॉन्फ़िगरेशन
फाइल्स। Windows कैन ऑटोमेट ए वैरायटी ऑफ
रिपीटेटिव टास्क सच एज द मास रोल आउट और
इंस्टॉलेशन ऑफ Windows, Windows ऑन मेनी
सिस्टम्स। अब Windows के अंदर एक फीचर
प्रोवाइड किया जाता है जिसे जिससे हम क्या
कर सकते हैं? मल्टीपल सिस्टम्स पर एक साथ
ऑटोमेटेड तरीके से इंस्टॉलेशन कर सकते हैं
बिना मैनुअली सेटअप के।
फॉर एग्जांपल्स अगर आप एक सिस्टम
एडमिनिस्ट्रेटर हो या फिर आपने कभी सिस्टम
एडमिनिस्ट्रेटर की जॉब की हो और अगर आपको
टास्क दे दिया जाए कि आप एक काम करो हमारी
कंपनी के अंदर 10 या 15 या 20 या 50
कंप्यूटरटर्स हैं और सब पे Windows
इंस्टॉल करना है तो सोच के देखिए कि अगर
आपको मैनुअली करना पड़ जाए तो कितना तो
टाइम लगेगा और कितना बोरिंग होगा। और इसी
चीज को अवॉइड करने के लिए इसी इसी टाइम को
बचाने के लिए यह फीचर्स प्रोवाइड किया गया
है Windows के अंदर कि आप 10 से 50 सिस्टम
या जितने भी सिस्टम्स है सब पे एक साथ
ऑटोमेटिकली Windows इंस्टॉल कर सकते हो।
यह ऐसा या मल्टीपल सिस्टम इंस्टॉल कर सकते
हो। दिस इज टिपिकली डन थ्रू द यूज़ ऑफ द
अनअटेंडेड Windows सेटअप यूटिलिटी व्हिच
इज यूज्ड टू ऑटोमेट द मास इंस्टॉलेशन और
डिप्लॉयमेंट ऑफ Windows ओन सिस्टम्स।
इसलिए Microsoft ने क्या किया? एक
अनअटेंडेड Windows सेटअप यूटिलिटी बनाई
जिसमें Windows का इंस्टॉलेशन
फुल्ली ऑटोमेटिक
होता था। ठीक है? होता है सॉरी होता था
नहीं। फुल्ली ऑटोमेशन मोड में हो सकता है।
दिस टूल यूटिलाइज द कॉन्फ़िगरेशन फाइल्स
दैट कंटेन स्पेसिफिक कॉन्फ़िगरेशंस एंड
यूजर अकाउंट क्रेडेंशियल्स स्पेशली द
एडमिनिस्ट्रेटर अकाउंट पासवर्ड। और यह
यूटिलिटी क्या करती है? ये यूटिलिटी एक
एक्सml
टाइप की फाइल कॉन्फ़िगरेशंस का यूज करती
है। एक्सML आपको पता है एक्सटेंसेबल
मार्कअप लैंग्वेज ऑलरेडी आप देख चुके हैं।
उस फाइल्स का यूज़ करती है अपनी
कॉन्फ़िगरेशंस के लिए जिसके अंदर क्या होता
है? सिस्टम्स की कॉन्फ़िगरेशंस होती हैं।
उसके सेटअप की इंस्ट्रक्शंस होती है।
डिफॉल्ट एडमिन अकाउंट्स होते हैं।
एडमिनिस्ट्रेटर पासवर्ड्स होते हैं। या जो
एडिशनल यूजर अकाउंट्स है जो आप सेटअप करना
चाहते हो उनकी भी डिटेल्स उसके अंदर स्टोर
होती है। यस, हम कह सकते हैं कि इसके अंदर
एडमिन पासवर्ड भी इस फाइल के अंदर होता
है। अगर यह फाइल आपको उस सिस्टम्स के ऊपर
मिलती हैं। सबको पता है कि किस केस में
फाइल मिल सकती है। तभी आप पूछोगे सर कि
एडमिन पासवर्ड इस फाइल के अंदर क्यों
स्टोर किया जाता है? अब सबको पता है कि
अगर आपको Windows को फुल्ली ऑटोमेटेड वे
से इंस्टॉल करना है। जैसे हार्ड ड्राइव
फॉर्मेटिंग करनी है, पीसी का नेम सेट करना
है, रीजन सेट करना है, टाइम टाइम सेटिंग
करनी है, एडमिन अकाउंट क्रिएट करना है और
एडमिन पासवर्ड सेट करना है। तो, यह सारे
काम क्या है? ऑटोमेटिकली करने हैं। तो,
उसके लिए आपको क्या चाहिए? एडमिन पासवर्ड
चाहिए। और वो कहां पर डिफाइन किया जाता
है? इस फाइल के अंदर क्योंकि जब फर्स्ट
टाइम जब आप इंस्टॉल करते हो तो सबसे पहले
एडमिन अकाउंट क्रिएट होता है। देन उसके
बाद फर्दर आपकी इंस्टॉलेशन होती है। तो यह
सारी चीजें डिफाइन होती है आपकी इस फाइल
के अंदर। कौन सी अनअटेंडेड जो सेटअप
यूटिलिटी इस फाइल के अंदर आपकी ये
कॉन्फ़िगर होती है। तो इसीलिए इस फाइल के
अंदर आपको एडमिनिस्ट्रेटर का पासवर्ड भी
प्रीडफाइंड देखने को मिलता है। अब इस
कॉन्फ़िगरेशनंस में क्या-क्या होता है?
जैसे आपके एडिशनल यूज़र्स की डिटेल्स होगी,
ऑटो लॉगिन्स की सेटिंग्स होगी या हम बात
करें एडमिनिस्ट्रेटर्स यूजरनेम पासवर्ड ये
सारी चीजें इस फाइल के अंदर डिफाइन होती
हैं। इफ दी अनअटेंडेड विंडोज सेटअप
कॉन्फ़िगरेशन फाइल्स आर लेफ्ट ऑन द टारगेट
सिस्टम आफ्टर इंस्टॉलेशन दे कैन रिवील
यूजर अकाउंट क्रेडेंशियल्स दैट कैन बी
यूज़्ड बाय अटैकर्स टू ऑथेंटिकेट विद द
Windows टारगेट लेजिटमेटली। अब प्रॉब्लम
तब होती है जब Windows इंस्टॉल होने के
बाद एडमिनिस्ट्रेटर्स इन फाइल्स को डिलीट
करना भूल जाते हैं। और अगर यह फाइल
अटैकर्स को मिल जाए तो उसको एडमिन
पासवर्ड्स मिल जाएगा। उसको ऑटो लॉगिन
क्रेडिेंशियल मिल जाएंगे। वो लेजिटमेटली
ऑथेंटिकेट कर पाएगा और उसको कोई भी
एक्सप्लइट की जरूरत नहीं है। इस केस में
सबसे बड़ी बात सारी चीजें उसको ऑटोमेटिकली
मिल जाएगी। मतलब वह Windows में कुछ भी कर
सकता है। मतलब कोई भी फाइल डिलीट कर सकता
है। कुछ भी कर सकता है। या कभी भी Windows
के अंदर आ जा सकता है बिना किसी उसके अ
बोल सकते हैं परमिशन क्योंकि उसके पास
ऑथराइजेशन है क्योंकि उसके पास लेजिटमेट
यूजरनेम और पासवर्ड है। क्रेडेंशियल्स है।
मतलब डायरेक्ट लॉगिन कर सकता है। वो कुछ
भी फाइल चेंज कर सकता है। अगर उसको एडमिनस
के प्लीजेस मिलते हैं। वह अपने यूजर से
दूसरे यूज़र्स में एस्केलेशन कर सकता है।
मतलब बहुत कुछ कर सकता है। एवरीवन क्लियर
कि यह फाइल कौन सी है? इस फाइल का पर्पज
क्या है? एवरीवन क्लियर? सबको ये चीज समझ
में आई कि इस फाइल का पर्पज क्या है?
व्हाट इज द पर्पज ऑफ दिस फाइल?
सबको समझ में आया ना? व्हाट इज द पर्पज ऑफ
दिस फाइल?
दे आर ओनली 13 या 16 स्टूडेंट्स। क्या बात
क्लास में मजा नहीं आ रहा आप लोगों को? या
मेरा पढ़ाने का तरीका थोड़ा अच्छा नहीं लग
रहा। बताओ बताओ जल्दी से।
मैं बदल लूंगा तरीका। कोई इशू नहीं है।
मुश्किल से 12 से 15 स्टूडेंट्स आते हो आप
लोग।
तो चलिए अनअटेंडेड विंडो सेटअप दी
अनअटेंडेड विंडो सेटअप यूटिलिटी विल
टिपिकली यूटिलाइज वन ऑफ द फॉलोइंग
कॉन्फ़िगरेशंस फाइल दैट कंटेंस यूजर अकाउंट
एंड सिस्टम कॉन्फ़िगरेशन इनेशन।
तो यहां पर दो लोकेशनेशंस आपको प्रोवाइड
की गई है। Windows के अंदर पैंथर
अनअटेंडेड.xml
या Windows Paner ऑटो ऑटो अनअटेंडXML
यह मोस्ट कॉमन लोकेशन है जिसके 80% चांसेस
हैं कि इस फॉर्म में हो या थोड़ा बहुत ऐसे
हो सकता है कि सी लोकल डिस्क सी Windows
panर उसके बाद अनअटेंडेड फोल्डर फोल्डर के
अंदर अनअटेंडेड एक्सml या ऑटो
अनअटेंडेडXML
80 टू 90% क्या है कि यह कॉमन टेक्निक्स
है। ऐसे ही मिल सकता है अगर आपको फाइंड
आउट करनी हो। अब दो 10 परसेंटेज के चांसेस
बढ़ जाते हैं जो अदर लोकेशनेशंस पर जो
ओईएम स्पेसिफिक होती है या कंपनी टू कंपनी
डिपेंड करती है या और कई चीजों पर डिपेंड
करती है वो लिस्ट आपको मैं प्रोवाइड कर
दूंगा। इसका आर्टिकल्स आपको जल्दी मिलेगा।
इसका बहुत जल्दी मिलेगा। लास्ट का मैंने
अभी तक नहीं कर पाया। उसके लिए मैं
बिल्कुल भी टाइम नहीं दे पाया। तो बट इसका
आई प्रॉमिस इसका आर्टिकल आपको बहुत जल्दी
मिलेगा। उस आर्टिकल में बहुत ज्यादा
डिटेल्स मिलेगी। तो सबसे पहले हम क्या कर
सकते हैं? इन दो लोकेशनेशंस को देख सकते
हैं। कहां पर यह फाइल अवेलेबल है या नहीं
है। अगर आपको यह फाइल अनअटेंडेड एक्सml या
ऑटो अनअटेंडल फाइल देखने को मिलती है तो
फिर
मतलब 100% आपकी लॉटरी लगेगी क्योंकि इसमें
क्रेडेंशियल्स मिलेंगे ही मिलेंगे क्योंकि
इसका यूज किया जाता है ऑटोमेटिकली
कॉन्फ़िगरेशनंस के लिए। क्लियर? ऑटोमेशन
कॉन्फ़िगरेशनंस के लिए।
तो एज ए सिक्योरिटी प्रिकॉशन दी पासवर्ड
स्टर्ड इन द अनअटेंडेड विंडो सेटअप
कॉन्फ़िगरेशन फाइल मे बी इंकडेड मी बेस 64
और क्या होता है कि सिक्योरिटी प्रिकॉशंस
के लिए इसमें जो पासवर्ड होगा बेस 64 में
आपको देखने को मिलता है और सबको पता है
बेस 64 को तो हम बहुत ही आसानी से क्या कर
सकते हैं
डिकोड कर सकते हैं कर सकते हैं या नहीं कर
सकते बताइए डिकोड कर सकते हैं या नहीं कर
सकते बताओ कर सकते हैं
बिल्कुल कर सकते हैं।
ओके।
तो
आज का जो पहला हमारा टेक्निक है आपको जैसे
मैंने बताया हमारा टारगेट क्या है?
अनअटेंडेड विंडो सेटअप फाइल्स को फाइंड
आउट करना। उसके बाद हमें प्रिज मतलब
प्रिलज एस्केलेशन के बाद हमें क्या करना
है? एडमिन अकाउंट पे शिफ्ट करना। समझ में
आ गया? एडमिन अकाउंट पर हमें शिफ्ट करना
है। तो चलिए एक सीटीएफ चैलेंज है और
सीटीएफ चैलेंज मैं आपको एक्सप्लेन कर देता
हूं कि NOV टेक इंडस्ट्री वन ऑफ द अभी एक
अजमशन है कोई है नहीं। नोवाटेक इंडस्ट्री
वन ऑफ द वर्ल्ड लार्जेस्ट आईटी
इंफ्रास्ट्रक्चर प्रोवाइडर इज प्रिपेयरिंग
द डिप्लॉयमेंट ऑफ देयर अपकमिंग नोवा एज
क्लस्टर ए टेक्नोलॉजी दैट कुड डोमिनेट द
क्लाउड मार्केट टू पुश आउट देयर इंटरनल
डेवलपमेंट सर्वर रैपिडली द सिस्टम
डेप्लॉयमेंट टीम इनिशिएट ए मार्स ऑटोमेटेड
सर्वर इंस्टॉलेशन पावर्ड बाय Windows
अनअटेंडेड सेटअप ऑटोमेशन
डेडलाइन वाज़ टाइट प्रेशर वाज़ इमस
मिस्टेक्स वर इनवेंटिबल। मतलब कहने का
मतलब क्या है कि इनका एक प्रोजेक्ट था। वह
पूरा इंफ्रास्ट्रक्चर क्लाउड पे सिक्योर
शिफ्ट कर रहे थे। एंड उन्होंने डिसाइड
किया कि वह अनअटेंडेड सेटअप ऑटोमेशन का
यूज करेंगे ताकि उनका काम जल्दी हो जाए।
क्योंकि डेडलाइन बहुत कम बहुत ज्यादा टाइट
थी। डेडलाइन बहुत पास में थी। प्रेशर बहुत
ज्यादा था और मिस्टेक्स तो हो ही रही थी।
अब जल्दबाजी में क्या हुआ कि यहां पर एक
एग्जांपल दिया गया है कि विन सर्वर
डिप्लॉय 01 एन इंटरनल डिप्लॉयमेंट नोड वाज
लेफ्ट इन ए टेंपरेरी बट वर्किंग कंडीशन ए
सिस्टम एडमिन क्रिएटेड ए टेंपरेरी एसएमबी
ट्रांसफर शेयर उसका नाम यह था डिप्लॉयमेंट
मीट फॉर इनिशियल यूज़ ओनली जिसको इंटरनल
यूज़ के लिए बनाया गया था बट एडमिन फॉरगेट
वन थिंग टू सिक्योर इट एडमिनिस्ट्रेटर
क्या किया उसको सिक्योर करना भूल गए एंड
व्हाट व्हाट द एडमिन एडमिन रियली फॉरगेट
वा दैट दिस सर्वर व्हिच हेल्ड द कीज़ टू
एवरीथिंग। और इस सर्वर पे क्या है कि कुछ
हिंट थी या कुछ कीज़ थी जो काफी इंपॉर्टेंट
थी इनके टास्क के लिए और जो बाय मिस्टेक
अंडर प्रेशर डेडलाइन की वजह से वो क्या कर
गए? भूल गए। तो यह थी कहानी छोटी सीटीएफ
चैलेंज की। अ भाई यू आर हायर्ड एज अ रेड
टीम ऑपरेटर्स एंड योर जॉब इज टू फाइंड आउट
व्हाटएवर एन एक्सटर्नल अटैकर्स कुड
एस्केलेट प्लेजेस एंड एक्सट्रैक्ट
सेंसिटिव क्लस्टर क्रेडेंशियल्स यूजिंग
एक्चुअल डिप्लॉयमेंट मिस्टेक मेड बाय देर
इंटरनल टीम। अब बात आई कि आपको एज ए रेड
टीम ऑपरेटर हायर किया गया और एज ए रेड टीम
ऑपरेटर आपकी जॉब थी कि एक एक्सटर्नल अटैकर
की तरह सोचकर अपने प्लेजेस को एस्केलेट
करना और उन सेचुनिटी इंफॉर्मेशन को फाइंड
आउट करना जो एडमिन के द्वारा गलतियां की
गई है ताकि यह ऑर्गेनाइजेशंस बिफोर किसी
बड़े अटैक का शिकार होने से पहले खुद ही
उसको अवॉइड कर सके अपनी शॉप शॉप टीम के
थ्रू तो आपका ऑब्जेक्टिव क्या है
इनफिल्ट्रेट
दिस सर्वर विदाउट रेिंग अलार्म लोकेट
डिप्लॉयमेंट मिस कॉन्फ़िगरेशंस रिकवर एनी
हिडन इंस्टॉलेशन आर्टिफेक्ट्स एक्सेस
इंटरनल एडमिन लेवल क्रेडेंशियल्स गेट
इंसाइड एंड एडमिनिस्ट्रेटर और आपको फाइनल
इंटेंट जो एडमिनिस्टर डेस्कटॉप पे आपको एक
फ्लैग मिला है वह आपको एक्सट्रैक्ट करना
है इंटरेस्टिंग गाइस मजा आने वाला है और
एक और अच्छी बात है कि
Windows डिफेंडर ऑन है। अभी तक की हमारी
लैब्स में मैक्सिमम Windows डिफेंडर ऑफ
था। यहां पर Windows डिफेंडर ऑन है। और
कुछ
लेवल मतलब कि बेसिक से प्लस थोड़ा लेवल
इसमें थोड़ा सा बोल सकते हो। बेसिक ही है।
वेरी हार्ड लैब नहीं है। मीडियम भी नहीं
है ये। बट बेसिक में थोड़ा सा प्लस है।
मतलब
थोड़े से रिस्ट्रिक्शन से ज्यादा नहीं है।
चलिए स्टार्ट करते हैं फिर।
वी आर एन अटैकर्स। चलिए हम अपनी जर्नी
स्टार्ट करते हैं। और स्टार्ट कैसे
करेंगे? हमारी मशीन ऑलरेडी स्टार्टअप मोड
में है और चलते हैं हम अपनी पेन टेस्टिंग
मशीन के ऊपर और देखते हैं कि हम क्या कर
सकते हैं और क्या नहीं कर सकते। क्योंकि
हमारा फाइनल गोल क्या है? थ्रिलेज
एस्केलेशन करना। ओके। तो एज एंड रेटिम
अटैकर्स हमें टारगेट आईपी मिला है। टारगेट
आईपी क्या है कि मैं आपको बता देता हूं।
टारगेट आईपी एक बार मैं ज़ूम कर देता हूं।
सबको दिखाई दे रहा है 192.168
42 दिस इज़ आवर टारगेट IP दिस इज़ आवर
टारगेट IPपी एड्रेस। सबको क्लियर है
टारगेट आईपी एड्रेस?
ओके। तो चलिए फिर कैसे करते हैं?
हम सबसे पहले क्या करने वाले हैं? बताओ।
सबसे पहले हमारा टास्क क्या है?
सबसे पहला टास्क हमारा यह है कि यह पता
लगाना कि आपका टारगेट अलाइव है या नहीं
है। कौन-कौन से पोर्ट ओपन है, क्या
ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम चल रहा है, कौन-कौन सी
सर्विज चल रही है, अटैक सरफेस क्या हो
सकता है? क्या मिस कॉन्फ़िगरेशन की
पॉसिबिलिटी है? और नेटवर्क एनवायरमेंट किस
टाइप का है। यह सारी चीजें हम पता करने
वाले हैं। तो, सबसे पहले हम क्या करने
वाले हैं? पिंक करने वाले हैं कि एसएमपी
ब्लॉक हो रहा है या नहीं हो रहा। तो मैं
आपको बताया कि चीजें शायद आपके हिसाब से
ना हो और भी अभी देखो आईसीएमपी ब्लॉक नहीं
है मतलब इसमें आईसीएमपी रिक्वेस्ट को
ब्लॉक नहीं किया जा रहा तो वेरी गुड सर्वर
आपका लाइव है एक्टिव है तो चलिए हम एक काम
करते हैं कि बार-बार सर्वर बोल रहे हैं सर
है क्या चीज यह हमें तो नहीं पता है एक
चीज हुई कि इसका डीटीएल वैल्यू 128 है तो
वी कैन अस्यूम कि यह Windows मशीन हो सकती
है बट वी आर नॉट श्योर क्योंकि क्योंकि
डिटेल वैल्यू भी तो बदली जा सकती है। तो
चलिए हम एनम मैप का यूज़ करते हैं। एन मैप
उसके बाद हफन हम यूज़ करेंगे पी एन उसके
बाद हफन हफन टॉप हफन पोर्ट्स हम पोर्ट
स्कैनिंग करते हैं। उसके बाद टॉप 1000
पोर्ट्स को जल्दी से हो जाएगा। 192.168.0
160.142
चलिए फिर हिट एंटर किया। देखते हैं कि
हमें यहां क्या मिलने वाला है और क्या
नहीं मिलने वाला। यह भी चीज हम देख लेते
हैं।
तभी आएगा इंटरेस्ट इसमें। इतना हार्ड नहीं
है। बस इसमें क्या है कि Windows डिफेंडर
के रिस्ट्रिकशंस तो जरूर हैं। देखिए यहां
पर क्या मिला आपको? पोर्ट 80 http पोर्ट
135 139 443
ये रही अब मुझे यह बताओ कि कौन सा पोर्ट
किस चीज के लिए है मुझे पोर्ट 80 सबको पता
है किस चीज के लिए जल्दी से बताओ जल्दी से
जो जो मैं पूछ रहा हूं विद इन वन सेकंड आप
जल्दी से चैट में लिखिए पोर्ट 84
ओके पोर्ट 135 या 139
पोर्ट
पोर्ट 135 139 किसके लिए हैं?
किसके लिए हो सकते हैं?
ओके।
वेरी गुड पोर्ट 443
जल्दी बताओ पोर्ट 443
बिल्कुल जल्दी जल्दी-जल्दी बताओ
ओके पोर्ट 445
पोर्ट 445
4.5
बिल्कुल एसएमबी पोर्ट 3389
और 5985 दोनों बताओ जल्दी ये कौन से हो
सकते हैं
बिल्कुल दूसरा पोर्ट 5985
जल्दी बताओ 5985 बिलकुल वेरी गुड जिसने
मेरी क्लास सिंसियरली अटेंड की है सबको
पता है यह सब चीज हम कर चुके हैं। तो चलिए
फिर अभी हम एक काम कर लेते हैं। हमने टॉप
1000 पोर्ट्स को स्कैन किया था। हो सकता
है कि और भी कोई पोर्ट्स हो जो हिडन हो
सकते हैं। तो हम एक काम करते हैं एन मैप
स्कैन करते हैं। हफन सिंस स्कैन करते हैं।
हफन सारे पोर्ट्स को स्कैन करते हैं। एक
बार पिन स्कैन
हो सकता है पॉसिबिलिटी बिल्कुल कुछ भी हो
सकती है। तो हम 192.168.42
और हिट एंटर हमने कर दिया। इट विल टेक
टाइम एंड डोंट वरी।
तो एक चीज तो मुझे पता चल गया कि आप लोगों
को नॉलेज तो हो गई धीरे-धीरे बिल्कुल आप
लोगों को बिल्कुल धीरे-धीरे नॉलेज तो हो
गई है तो अच्छी बात है
इट विल टेक टाइम बट नो प्रॉब्लम।
भाई इससे पता चल जाएगा कि ओके 19% हुआ है।
तो एक काम करते हैं तब तक हम पोर्ट 80 चेक
करते हैं कि पोर्ट 80 पर है क्या चीज।
चलिए देखते हैं पोर्ट 80 पर कुछ है तो
देखते हैं और अगर नहीं है तो और भी अच्छी
बात है। तो पोर्ट 80 को चेक कर लेते हैं
और एक बार कंट्रोल shift प्लस प्लस अरे
इधर नहीं चाहिए प्लस तो हम लिख रहे हैं
192.168.42
वाओ यह क्या है
पोर्ट 80 पर यह क्या है
कि क्या हो सकता है यह बताओ
यह क्या हो सकता है
बिल्कुल एक वेब सर्वर आईएस वेब सर्वर मतलब
कौन सी मशीन है आपकी
आपकी कौन सी मशीन
Windows सर्वर मतलब टारगेट तो आपका विंडो
है तो कोई नहीं इट विल टेक टाइम। इसमें
देखते हैं। अभी 88% हो चुका है। पोर्ट 443
और चेक करते हैं 443 पर क्या है? चलिए फिर
443 पे चलते हैं हम। एचटीटीपीएस कर देते
हैं इधर एचटीटीपी की जगह और हिट एंटर
वार्निंग
यह क्या है?
एडवांस करते हैं। देखते हैं। इनवैलिड
सर्टिफिकेट सर्टिफिकेट नॉट ट्रस्ट बिकॉज़
सेल्फ साइन सर्टिफिकेट है। ओके एक्सेप्ट द
रिस्क इस पे देखते हैं। यह भी सेम है।
यह भी सेम है। मतलब हमें यहां पर कुछ नहीं
मिला। मतलब हमें यहां पर कुछ नहीं मिला।
कह सकते हैं। और सोर्स पेज और देख लेते
हैं करके।
इंस्पेक्ट नहीं करेंगे हम। हम सोर्स व्यू
पे सर्च कर सकते हैं हम
क्योंकि यहां वैसे कुछ मिलने वाला है नहीं
कुछ नहीं वैसे इसमें होगा
तो अभी इसमें और देखते हैं हमें यहां क्या
मिला तो चलिए यहां पर भी हमें कुछ नहीं
मिला हमें सिर्फ पोर्ट 80 पोर्ट 1335
पोर्ट 1339 443 445 338957 और यह है एक
अननोन पोस्ट 4968 टीसीp इसके अलावा हमें
कुछ नहीं मिला तो अभी हम क्या करने वाले
हैं अभी हम करते हैं सर्विस वर्जन
डिटेक्शन सर्विस वर्जन डिटेक्शन करते हैं
डिफॉल्ट स्क्रिप्ट स्कैन करते हैं और चलने
देते हैं तो क्योंकि यही पोर्ट आने वाले
हैं तो एन मैप उसके बाद हफन एस सर्विस
वर्जन डिटेक्शन उससे हमें थोड़ी सी कुछ तो
डिटेल मिलेगी देन उसके बाद बाद हम क्या
करते हैं? सर्विस वर्जन डिटेक्शन हफन
डिफ़ॉल्ट स्कैन और उसके बाद हम इतना ही
काफी है।
192.168.1.42
इतनी चीजें मैं इसलिए बता रहा हूं ताकि आप
लोगों को क्लियर हो जाए। और एक और काम
करना था मुझे। इसको मैं स्टॉप करता हूं
अभी और मैं इसके साथ
ओएस डिटेक्शन
और साथ में लगा लेते हैं ताकि आपको क्लियर
हो। ओएस डिटेक्टेंस भी इसमें साथ में कर
लेते हैं। तो चलिए ओएस डिटेक्शन कर लेते
हैं साथ में 192.168.142
चलिए फिर थोड़ा सा वेट करेंगे। देखते हैं
कि हमें क्या इंफॉर्मेशन यहां पर देखने को
मिले क्योंकि हमें स्टेप बाय स्टेप जाना
पड़ेगा। पोर्ट 80 पर हमें कुछ नहीं मिला।
पोर्ट 443 पर हमें कुछ नहीं मिला। कुछ मिल
सकता है या नहीं मिल सकता मुझे बताओ। 443
पर कुछ मिल सकता है या नहीं मिल सकता? आप
लोगों के लिए सच में नई चीज है यह आज।
क्या पोर्ट नंबर 443 पर हमें कुछ मिल सकता
है या नहीं मिल सकता? मुझे यह बताओ जस्ट।
बाकी तो हम देख लेंगे। पहले मुझे यह बताओ
कि पोर्ट मिल सकता है या नहीं मिल सकता।
बस हां या ना। अगर हां तो क्या मिल सकता
है? हमें कौन सा स्टेप परफॉर्म करना
पड़ेगा?
फील नो ओके कोई यस बता रहा है या सबका नो
है?
कोई भी बता सकता है। देखो चलिए यहां पर
देखते हैं हमें क्या-क्या मिला है। पोर्ट
80 http देखो iएस Windows सर्वर ओके वर्जन
हमें मिल गया Microsoft is 10.0 वेरी गुड
पोटेंशियली रिस्की मेथड ट्रेस ट्रेस मेथड
इस पे एक्टिव है। 1335 139 443 पर क्या
है? 443 पर कुछ मिला है। इन्होंने क्या
दिया? एसएसएल और http microsoft आईएस
एचटीटीपीडी एसएसएल सर्टिफिकेट यहां पर यह
सोसो नोवा टेक डेप्लॉयमेंट एचtf डॉट लोकल
सीएन नेम है इंटर्न और उसके बाद वैलिडिटी
इसकी लिखी है http windows सर्वर है
पोटेंसी स्कीम स्ट्रेस है। तो इसमें कुछ
इंटरेस्टिंग चीजें लग रही है आपको या नहीं
लग रही?
उसके बाद 3389
टारगेट नेम नेट बायस डोमेन नेम उसके बाद
यह है प्रोडक्ट वर्जन ओके 5357 नॉट 5985
नॉट फाउंड मैक एड्रेस है हमारे पास रनिंग
micro Windows सर्वर 2019 वाओ 97%ेज गैस
है इसका बाकी Window 10 भी हो सकता है और
तो इसका मतलब देखो सर्वर तो है मतलब
Windows सर्वर 2019 हो सकता है क्योंकि
आईआईएस सर्वर आपके Windows 10 11 पे नहीं
चलता सर्वर पे चलता है तो Windows सर्वर
2019 हमारा टारगेट है। नेट बायस में कुछ
मिला नहीं मिला। तो यहां पर कोई
इंटरेस्टिंग इनेशन हमें मिली या नहीं मिली
बताओ।
तो यह तो हमने कर लिया रिकॉन और रिकॉन में
हमें पता चल गया
कि इतने सारे पोर्ट ओपन है। कभी किसी ने
यह बताओ एसएसएल या एचटीटी पे एनुमिनेशन
किया है?
और अगर एसएसएल एनुमरेशन हमें करना है तो
क्यों करते हैं हम?
अगर हम एसएसएल एनुमरेशन कभी किसी ने किया
है?
एसएसएल एनुमरेशन नई चीज आप लोगों के लिए
एसएसएल एनुमरेशन
क्योंकि पोर्ट के हिसाब से अगर हम देखें
तो हमें एसएसएल एनुमरेशन नेक्स्ट स्टेप
परफॉर्म करना पड़ेगा। तो यह बताओ एसएसएल
एनुमरेशन अगर हमें करना है तो क्यों करना
पड़ेगा हमें? क्यों करेंगे हम?
देखो
एसएसएल एनुमिनेशन तभी कर सकते हैं जब आपका
सर्टिफिकेट अप्लाई होगा। ओके मतलब
सर्टिफिकेट अप्लाई होगा पोर्ट एचटीटीपीएस
यूज़ हो रहा होगा पोर्ट 443
मेन पर्पस होता है आपका एसएसआर एनुमिशन का
मेटा डेटा लीकेज को ढूंढना। अब मेटा डाटा
में क्या होता है कि आपके जो सर्टिफिकेट
के जो सब्जेक्ट या जो फील्ड्स होते हैं
उनमें कई बार आपको सेंसिटिव इंफॉर्मेशन
मिल जाते हैं जिसको हम इग्नोर कर देते
हैं। कई बार वहां पर यूजर नेम भी लीक हो
जाता है। कई बार इंटरनल इंफॉर्मेशन लीक हो
जाती है। कौन सी कंट्री है? उसकी
एक्सपायरी डेट हो गई या सफर एल्गोरििदम
अगर वीक से सफर एल्गोरिदम यूज़ हो रही है
तो उससे भी आप क्या कर सकते हो कि उस
इंक्रिप्शन को ब्रेक कर सकते हो। टीएलएस
का कौन सा वर्जनंस है मतलब सर्टिफिकेट की
मिस कॉन्फ़िगरेशंस को मतलब वहां पर क्या है
कि इंफॉर्मेशन नहीं होनी चाहिए थी जो वो
इंफॉर्मेशन आपको देखने को मिल जाए। अब
सीधी सी बात है अगर पोर्ट 443 का यूज़ किया
जा रहा है मतलब HTTPS ओपन है सर्टिफिकेट
को आप देख सकते हो और उसके अंदर से
इंफॉर्मेशन गैब कर सकते हो और उस
इंफॉर्मेशन के गेस पर आप एक आईडिया लगा
सकते हो कि वह इंफॉर्मेशन आपके काम आएगी
या नहीं आएगी। समझ में आ गई यह चीज कि हम
एचटीटीपी एनुमिशन की बात करें या फिर हम
एसएसएल एनुमिशंस क्यों करते हैं? तो
एसएसएल एनुमिशन के लिए चलो एक काम करते
हैं। तो कंफर्म कर लिया एक चीज तो आपको
पता है कि पोर्ट 443 पर क्या यूज़ हो रहा
है आपका microsoft आईएस। तो एनमप में एक
स्क्रिप्ट होती है। वह स्क्रिप्ट होती है
आपकी यह चेक करने के लिए कि जो सर्टिफिकेट
है उसके अंदर क्या-क्या मेटा डाटा इनेशन
है। और उस स्क्रिप्ट का वो स्क्रिप्ट कौन
सी एनमप हफन हम यूज़ करेंगे पोर्ट फोर्ट
पोर्ट का यूज़ करने वाले हैं हम पोर्ट 443
उसके बाद हम हफन हफन स्क्रिप्ट उसके बाद
स्क्रिप्ट का नाम है एसएसएल शर्ट एसएसएल
शर्ट 192.168.1.42
और हिट एंटर करते हैं।
यह देखो एचटीटीपीएस
एसएसएल सर्टिफिकेट का सब्जेक्ट क्या है या
कॉमन नेम की बात करें तो सीएन देखो कॉमन
नेम क्या है इंटर्न
ऑर्गेनाइजेशन का नाम क्या है नोवाटेक
डेप्लॉयमेंट बिल्कुल
सब्जेक्ट अल्टरनेटिव नेम डीएनएस cटीएफ
डॉटल
cटीएफ लोकल मतलब कुछ आपको डोमेन
इंफॉर्मेशन मिल रही है। कॉमन नेम में हो
सकता है कि इंटर्न आपका यूजरनेम हो।
इंटर्न आपका यूजरनेम हो। हो सकता है ना
किसी पीसी का यूजरनेम हो या किसी इंसान का
नाम हो या कुछ किसी पर्पस से तो आया होगा
ना। यह इस का कॉमन नेम देखो वही है।
पब्लिक की आरएसए है। पब्लिक की बिट यह है।
60 टू 56 विद आरएसए एल्गोरिदम का यूज़ किया
गया। गुड। MD5 सा है। यह होके मैक है। यह
चीज हो सकती है। और भी चीजें देख सकते हो।
अभी और भी टूल्स है जिनका आप यूज़ कर सकते।
ओपन एसएसएल का आप यूज़ कर सकते हो। कैसे?
ओपन एसएसएल उसके बाद एस अंडरs क्लाइंट
एस अंडरs क्लाइंट हफन कनेक्ट
हफन कनेक्ट 192.168.1.42
उसके बाद पोर्ट नंबर 443 उसके बाद हमें
क्या करना है? हफन शो सर्टिफिकेट सो
सर्टिफिकेट
यही है। हिट एंटर करते हैं। देखो इसमें
बहुत सारी इंफॉर्मेशन है। पूरा सर्टिफिकेट
की इनेशन है। वही सेम चीज है जो हमने
फाइंड आउट की। वही सेम चीज हमने फाइंड आउट
की। वही तो है। जैसे कि आप देखोगे नोवा
टॉक डेप्लॉयमेंट सेल्फ साइंस सर्टिफिकेट
है। सेल्फ साइंस सर्टिफिकेट मतलब चांसेस
वही है जिसने उसको साइन किया हो। यूजर नेम
भी हो सकता है। सीएम कॉमन नेम इंटर्न सीएन
नेम इंटर्न
मतलब सेंसिटिव इंफॉर्मेशन हो सकती है।
सीएन क्या आपका कॉमन नेम कॉमन नेम में
आपका क्या होता है? यूजरनेम हो सकता है।
ओय की इंफॉर्मेशन आपको मिल सकती है। जैसे
कि आपकी ऑर्गेनाइजेशन यूनिट की मतलब ओयू
मतलब ऑर्गेनाइजेशनल यूनिट। सिटी की
इंफॉर्मेशन मिल सकती है। स्टेट की
इंफॉर्मेशन मिल मिल सकती है। कई बार आपको
ईमेल आईडी तक भी मिल सकती है। प्रोजेक्ट
का नाम मिल सकता है। डिपार्टमेंट की
डिटेल्स मिल सकती है या उस सर्वर की
इंफॉर्मेशन मिल सकती है यहां पर। यह सारी
चीजें यह मेन पर्पस था हमारा इस चीज को
करने का। चलो यह चीज हो गई। एक और कमांड
होती है। आप क्या करोगे? एक टूल होता है।
कौन सा? हम कह उस टूल का नाम है एसएसएल
स्कैन। तो सूडो एपीटी करोगे। इंस्टॉल करो।
वैसे इंस्टॉल होता नहीं बाय डिफ़ॉल। वैसे
इंस्टॉल मिलेगा लेटेस्ट काली में एसएसएल
स्कैन इसको इंस्टॉल करोगे तो आप इंस्टॉल
कर लीजिए अगर नहीं होगा तो अगर होगा तो
आपको बता देगा ऑलरेडी इंस्टॉल्ड तो यह
ऑलरेडी इंस्टॉल्ड है तो इसका भी यूज़ कर
सकते हो एसएसएल स्कैन इसमें बहुत ज्यादा
डिटेल्स में इंफॉर्मेशन आती है
192.1684142
आज मैं आपको जो चीज बता रहा हूं काफी
इंपॉर्टेंट चीज है क्योंकि आपको बहुत काम
आने वाली है कभी भी काम आ सकती है चीज
देखो यहां देखो बहुत कुछ आपको डिटेल्स
इनफेशन मिलने वाली है उस पर्टिकुलर एसएसएल
सर्टिफिकेट के बारे में। देखो यहां पर
देखो
ओपन एसएसएल कनेक्टेड टू टेस्टिंग एसएसएल
सर्वर ऑन पोर्ट 443 यूजिंग अभी देखो
एसएसएल वर्जन कौन सा हो सकता है यहां पर
देखो टीएलएस वर्जन इनेबल्ड वन टू 1.2 तक
है 1.3 डिसेबल्ड है सर्वर डज नॉट सपोर्ट
टीएलएस फॉल बैकक ये सपोर्ट नहीं करता मतलब
यह तो बहुत ज्यादा डिटेल्ड इनेशन है इसमें
शायद आपको इतनी चीजें समझ में नहीं आएंगी
मैं बस आपको बता रहा था अभी देखो ईश्वर
फिर से इंटर्न टर्न है मतलब
हमारे लिए यह काम का हो सकता है। हमारे
लिए बिल्कुल यह काम का हो सकता है अगर आप
लोगों ने सोचा भी नहीं होगा। एक और तो टूल
है नहीं। काफी इंफॉर्मेशन हमें तो मतलब
हमें एक यूजरनेम तो मिल गया। तो हमें काफी
इंफॉर्मेशन मिल गई। तो हमने क्या कर लिया?
स्टेप टू में स्टेप वन क्या किया? रिकॉन
किया। स्टेप टू में हमने क्या किया? आपके
एसएसएल एनुमिनेरेशन किया। उससे हमें
सर्टिफिकेट से मेटा कलेक्ट किया। मेटा
डाटा में हमें एक इंटरेस्टिंग फैक्टर मिला
है इंटर्न मतलब आपका यूजरनेम हो भी सकता
है और आपका यूजरनेम नहीं भी हो सकता।
नेक्स्ट स्टेप हमें क्या करना पड़ेगा अभी?
नेक्स्ट स्टेप हमें क्या करना पड़ेगा?
नेक्स्ट स्टेप हम क्या कर सकते हैं जो
आपको लगता है?
आपको पता है कौन-कौन से पोर्ट ओपन है। तो
नेक्स्ट स्टेप में हम क्या कर सकते हैं?
ये रहे हमारे ये पोर्ट ओपन है। ये ये चलो
यह हमारे पोर्ट्स ओपन है। पोर्ट 8043 से
हमें एक सेंसिटिव इनेशन मिली है। इंटर्न
अभी हम क्या कर सकते हैं?
बताओ कोई भी मुझे गाइड करेगा बताओ।
नेक्स्ट व्हाट विल बी आवर स्टे? यस 3389
इज ए ओपन बट बट बट बट ओके ब्रूट कर सकते
हो गुड।
चलो अच्छी बात है बट उसके लिए कर सकते हैं
आरडीपी ब्रूटफोर्स कर सकते हो बट रेट
लिमिटिंग होगी तो
Windows सर्वर 2019 अगर रेट लिमिटिंग मिल
गई तो
बताओ
ठीक है आरडीपी के अलावा और क्या कर सकते
हो
आरडीपी के अलावा और क्या कर सकते हो।
एसएमबी एनुमिनेशन नहीं कर सकते।
एसएमबी ओपन है तो हम यह चेक नहीं कर सकते।
एसएमबी एनुमिलेशंस
एसएमबी एनुमिशन
तो पहले एजी वाले काम करो ना। हार्ड वाले
बाद में कर लेना। जब कुछ रास्ता नहीं हो
तो ब्रूट फ़ोर्स बाद में कर लेंगे। पहले
एसएमबी एनोमरेशन नहीं कर सकते। तो चलिए
एसएमबी न्यूमरेशन करके देख लेते हैं।
नेक्स्ट स्टेप जो मैं आपको क्लियर कर चुका
हूं। पहले आसान जितने आसान रास्ते हैं
आपके सामने वो सारे फॉलो कर कीजिए। उसके
बाद हम देखते हैं। तो एसएमबी का वर्जन चेक
करते हैं। सबसे पहले एनमप हफन सर्विस
वर्जन डिटेक्शन हफन हफन स्क्रिप्ट। उसके
बाद एसएमबी प्रोटोकॉल क्योंकि ये चीज मैं
आपको सिखा चुका हूं।
आप बहुत जल्दी भावनाओं में बहकर ज्यादा
बड़े डिसीजन पर चले जाते हैं। पहले यह
वाला टास्क तो परफॉर्म कीजिए ना
192.168.142
हिट एंटर। तो यहां पे यह तो कंफर्म कर ले
कि एसएमबी का कौन सा प्रोटोकॉल यूज़ किया
जा रहा है। क्या हम उस पे कुछ कर सकते हैं
या नहीं कर सकते?
हां एसएमबी ओपन तो इजी है हमारे लिए अगर
एसएमबी पर कुछ देखो
एसएमबी का वर्जन मतलब 1 ओ तो है नहीं
जिसमें इटरनल ब्लू वनबिलिटी थी मतलब वो आप
परफॉर्म नहीं कर सकते वर्जन या तो 2 पॉइंट
है एसएमबी का या वर्जन 3.0 है मतलब वर्जन
टू या थ्री है एसएमबी वन नहीं है मतलब
इटरनल ब्लू जो अटैक था वह आप परफॉर्म नहीं
कर सकते हैं। तो आप सबके सबसे पहला स्टेप
एसएमबी एनुमिशन में क्या कर सकते हैं हम?
हम एसएमबी एनुमिशन में सबसे पहला स्टेप
क्या कर सकते हैं? क्या हम एनोनिमस चेक
नहीं करेंगे? कहीं बाय मिस्टेक मिस
कॉन्फ़िगर तो नहीं किया गया। एनोनिमसली
एक्सेसबल है या नहीं शेयर? यह चेक कर सकते
हैं या नहीं चेक कर सकते। बताइए। अगर चेक
कर सकते हैं तो कौन सी कमांड का यूज करने
वाले हैं हम?
एनोनिमस एक्सेस चेक कर सकते हैं हम।
ओके से कोई बाय मिस्टेक एनोनिमस एक्सेस
मिल जाए और वहां पर कुछ सेंसिटिव
इंफॉर्मेशन हमें मिल जाए या काम की चीज
हमें मिल जाए। बिल्कुल वेरी गुड। तो हम
यूज़ करेंगे एसएमबी क्लाइंट का यूज़ करेंगे।
एसएमबी क्लाइंट हफन एल उसके बाद यह
192.168.1.42
उसके बाद हफन कैपिटल n और हिट एंटर करते
हैं। कैपिटल n का मतलब हम एनोनिमस चेक
करना चाहते हैं। हिट एंटर
सेशन सेटअप फील्ड एंटी स्टेटस एक्सेस
डिनाइड।
इसका मतलब क्या हो सकता है?
इसका मतलब है एनोनिमस एक्सेस ब्लॉक है।
हमें क्रेडेंशियल्स चाहिए और Windows
सर्वर 2019, 2016, 2022 पे बाय डिफॉल्ट
एनोनिमस एक्सेस डिसेबल होता है जब तक उसको
इनेबल ना किया जाए खुद से। अगर आपको
एनोनिमस एक्सेस मिल जाता तो आपका जैकपॉट
लग जाता है। अभी अभी आपका जैकपॉट तो नहीं
लगा। मतलब हम फंस गए फिर से फंस गए तो एक
काम और कर लेते हैं। चलिए एक और टूल होता
हमारा कौन सा
एक और टूल होता है हमारा कौन सा लेटेस्ट
2025 में हम कौन सा टूल यूज़ कर सकते हैं
एक और बताओ दूसरा टूल जिससे और भी पहले हम
इंफॉर्मेशन रिकॉन कर रहे हैं कुछ मिले तो
एसएमबी के बेस पर उसके बाद देखेंगे हम
एनुमिनेशन बोल सकते हो हम एनुमिनेशन कर
रहे हैं अभी तो देखो एनm4 linx सुना है
सबने
NM4 Linux यह ओल्ड वर्जन था। लेटेस्ट
वर्जन है nm फॉर linx hfन ng
एनm फॉर linx hन ng hfन कैपिटल a और
1921 168
बिल्कुल कर सकते हैं। चलो हिट एंटर यहां
भी चेक कर लेते हैं हमें टारगेट इनेशन यह
है। यूजरनेम खाली है। रैंडम यूजरनेम भर
रखा है। पासवर्ड कुछ नहीं है। टाइम आउट 5
सेकंड
कुछ देखते हैं कुछ मिलेगा तो चेकिंग लिसनर
स्कैन चेकिंग एलप नथिंग चेकिंग एल डेप्स
चेकिंग एसएमबी एसएमबी एक्सेबल ऑन 445 यह
हमें भी पता है एसएमबी और नेट बॉयस
टेक्नोलॉजी का यूज़ किया जा रहा है नेट
बायस नेम्स एंड वर्क ग्रुप डोमेन की इनेशन
देखते हैं
वर्क स्टेशन सर्विस फाइल सर्वर सर्विस
एक्टिव है वर्क ग्रुप यह मैक एड्रेस है।
उसके बाद क्या है? एसएमबी वर्जन टू या
थ्री का यूज़ किया जाए। बिल्कुल ट्रू है।
एसएमबी प्रेफर्ड यह बता रहा है। एसएमबी
थ्री यूज़ किया गया है। उसके बाद कुछ
इंटरेस्टिंग इंफॉर्मेशन डोमेन नेम आपको
मिल गया। नेट बायस कंप्यूटर नेम आपको मिल
गया। फुल्ली क्वालिफाइड डोमेन नेम आपको
मिल गया। चलो और कुछ इंफॉर्मेशन हमारे
हमारे काम की नहीं। और कुछ इंफॉर्मेशन
हमारे काम की बिल्कुल भी नहीं मिली। उसके
अलावा हम क्या कर सकते हैं? एनोनिमस ब्लॉक
है। एनोनिमस चेक करने के लिए हमने चेक कर
लिया। अभी हमारे पास एक ही ऑप्शन है इसको
ब्रूट फोर्स करना। इसको ब्रूट फ़ोर्स करना।
क्रैक मैप X को भी हम ट्राई कर सकते हैं।
वैसे कैसे देख सकते हो आप कि क्रैकप एक्सक
काफी रेड टीम का बेस्ट टूल है ये। रेड
टिमर्स का बेस्ट टूल है। यह भी ज्यादातर
यूज़ किया जाता है। और अगर आप ओएसपी वगैरह
भी देने की सोच रहे हो तो यह टूल्स आपका
मार्क कर लीजिए। बहुत काम आने वाला है।
1.42
देखिए
तो यह ऑथेंटिकेशन फॉल्स है। मतलब मतलब अभी
हमारे पास हमें इसको क्या करना पड़ेगा?
ब्रूट फ़ोर्स करना पड़ेगा। तो हमारे पास
यूजर नेम है। तो एक काम करते हैं हम ब्रूट
फ़ोर्स करते हैं। ज्यादा टाइम नहीं
लगाएंगे। क्रैक एक्सक उसके बाद एसएमबी देन
हफन यू हमारे पास यूजरनेम हम देख रहे हैं
इंटर्न इंटर्न उसके बाद hfन पी पासवर्ड
लिस्ट मेंशन करेंगे अब हमारे पास roktxt
ही है जिसका हम यूज़ कर सकते हैं ब्रूटf ऑन
एसएमबी पोर्ट नंबर 445 एसएमबी ब्रूटf हम
कर रहे हैं तो हम कैसे करने वाले हैं अब
मैं एक काम क्लियर कर देता हूं ताकि आपको
जाके चीजें क्लियर हो जाए यहां अब स्क्रीन
के बिल्कुल नीचे दिखाई दे रहा होगा।
क्लियर कर देता हूं स्क्रीन आपको। चलिए तो
हम एक काम करते हैं। ये रहा
हफन यू यूजर इंटर्न क्योंकि जो हमने
सर्टिफिकेट के अंदर देखा था hfन पी वर्ड
लिस्ट देंगे। वर्ड लिस्ट हम क्या कर रहे
हैं? हमारी है डाउनलोड के अंदर r.txt
और हिट एंटर कर देते हैं और सक्सेस रेट
देखते हैं कितनी क्योंकि इट विल लॉट ऑफ इट
विल टेक टाइम लॉट ऑफ टाइम्स। ओके? तो देखो
थोड़ा सा वेट करते हैं। 5 मिनट में क्लियर
नहीं करा बट मेरे पास पता है कि वह
पासवर्ड इसके अंदर है और उस पासवर्ड से हम
क्या करेंगे?
लॉग इन करेंगे। क्योंकि यहां पर हमें
ब्रटफोर्स किया और अज्यूम करेंगे कि
ब्रटफोर्स करने के बाद हमें पासवर्ड मिल
गया। ब्रटफोर्स करने के बाद हमें मिल गया
पासवर्ड।
अज्यूम कर लें।
आप हाइड्रा से भी इसको कर सकते हो।
हाइड्रा के लिए होता है हाइड्रा हफन एल
उसके बाद यूजरनेम hfन कैपिटल पी वर्ड
लिस्ट उसके बाद एसएमबी ऐसे आप कर सकते हो।
हाइड्रा से भी आप कर सकते हो। आपको पता है
हाइड्रा से कैसे करते हैं? यह भी आपको पता
है। तो काफी समय लगने वाला है इसमें। तो
हम चलते हैं। अज्यूम करें कि हमें उसका
पासवर्ड मिल गया है। तो इसको हम ब्लॉक कर
दें। बंद कर दें एक बार। इट विल टेक लॉट
ऑफ टाइम भैया चलने दे क्योंकि सिस्टम स्लो
हो जाएगा हमारा। चलने दे
तो ब्रूट फ़ोर्स ही देखना पूरी क्लास में
आज।
तो चलिए एक काम कर देते हैं। हम इसको
स्टॉप कर देते हैं। आप लोग खुद से कर सकते
हो। वैसे ब्रुट फ़ोर्स मैं स्टॉप कर देता
हूं। स्टॉप स्टॉप स्टॉप स्टॉप रुको रुको
रुको क्लियर कर देता हूं मैं इसको स्क्रीन
क्लियर कर देता हूं तो अज्यूम हमारा
पासवर्ड है आपको पासवर्ड लिख देता हूं
यूजर नेम है आपका इंटर्न
और इसका जो पासवर्ड है वह है आपका
कहीं लिखा था मैंने विंटर
ये ये इसका पासवर्ड है ठीक है यह इसका
पासवर्ड है
ठीक है यह इसका पासवर्ड है विंटर 2024
एस्केलेशन मार्क्स। तो अभी हम क्या
करेंगे? अभी हम इसके थ्रू भी क्या कर सकते
हैं? क्योंकि एसएमबी में एनुमिनेशन करने
के लिए एक लेवल तक हम चेक कर सकते हैं।
उसके बाद हमें क्रेडेंशियल चाहिए अगर
फर्दर हमें हमें एनुमिनेशन करना है। तो हम
क्या करने वाले हैं अभी? एसएमबी क्लाइंट
एसएमबी क्लाइंट हफ एल उसके बाद
192.18
42 उसके बाद hfन u पहले हम क्रैक मैप x से
करेंगे तो सही रहेगा। इसको बाद में यूज़
करते हैं क्योंकि इससे हम उसमें ज्यादा
क्लेरिटी आती है चीजों की। शेयर की इनेशन
जानते हैं पहले हम तो हम क्या करने वाले
हैं? Crackmap एक्सेक्ट। यह हो गया आपका।
तो, हमारे पास यूजरनेम एंड पासवर्ड रखते
हैं हम। पासवर्ड है इसका विंटर।
विंटर 2024
एस्केलेशन मार्क्स उसके बाद hफ़न हफन शेयर
का न्यूमरेशन कर रहे हैं हम यहां पर।
शेयर हिट एंटर किया। यह देखिए हमें शेयर
मिले। यह रिमोट एडमिन यह बाय डिफ़ॉल्ट
इनेबल होता है। यह भी नहीं हो। अभी हमें
मिला रीड डिप्लॉयमेंट
रीड एक शेयर मिला हमें डिप्लॉयमेंट रीड के
नाम से तो रीड के नाम से हमें एक शेयर
मिला है। तो हम कैसे कर सकते हैं? तो हम
एसएमबी क्लाइंट की हेल्प से इसको डिप्लॉय
करेंगे। चलो हम एसएमबी क्लाइंट उसके बाद
चलिए 192.18.1.42
उसके बाद अभी एक काम करना भूल गया हम इनको
ले रखना पड़ेगा हमें
एसएमबी क्लाइंट डबल कोड के अंदर तो
42 डिप्लॉयमेंट कैसे कर सकते हैं? देखते
हैं हम
तो डिप्लॉयमेंट उसके बाद उसके ये था हमारा
डिप्लॉयमेंट
कॉपी सिलेक्शन से अह कॉपी पेस्ट
डिप्लॉयमेंट हो गया। देन उसके बाद
हफन इसको हम क्लोज कर देते हैं। हफन
कैपिटल यू उसके बाद आपका यूजरनेम इंटर्न
उसके बाद परसेंटेज
विंटर
यह रहा और हिट एंटर हमने कर दिया बट
समथिंग एल्स वी रोंग दैट इज लाइक
इसको सिंगल कोट करना पड़ेगा। तो हमें
ओके ओके सॉरी सॉरी
ओके मैं समझ गया समझ गया समझ गया समझ गया
आई एम सॉरी फॉर दैट
बिल्कुल बिल्कुल बिल्कुल बिल्कुल
अब सर्विसेस कर रही है।
क्लियर करते हैं।
चलिए एसएमबी क्लाइंट
192.168.1.42
अभी भी हमने गलती कर दी।
बहुत गलतियां होती है टाइपिंग में मोर
टाइम्स इसके लिए मुझे माफ कीजिएगा सबसे
होती हैं बट मैं बहुत ज्यादा गलतियां करता
हूं डिप्लॉयमेंट
उसके बाद हफन यू
प्रिंटर्न
परसेंटेज
प्रिंटर 2022
यह रहा और हिट एंटर कर देते अभी क्या इशू
है?
अभी क्या इशू है?
ओके। शायद हम फिर से कोई गड़बड़ कर रहे
हैं।
यस हमें मिल गया। एक्सेस हमें मिल गया।
एक्सेस हमें मिल गया। सिंगल कोट रखना था।
डबल कोट नहीं रखना था। तो एक्सेस हमें मिल
गया। और एक्सेस मिलने के बाद हम चेक करते
हैं अभी एलएस। यहां पर क्या देखने को मिल
रहा है? डिप्लॉयमेंट बैकअप। उसके बाद
सेटअप नोट्स
सेटअप नोट डॉटxt आपको देखने को मिल रही
है। तो उसके बाद हम एक काम करते हैं। फिर
इसको भी चेक कर लेते हैं। तो डिप्लॉयमेंट
बैकअप पे भी देखते हैं क्या चीज है। तो
अगर हम हेल्प साइल चेक करते हैं कि इसमें
और क्या-क्या कर सकते हैं। तो हम सीडी कर
सकते हैं इसमें। ओके। सीडी कर सकते हैं
नहीं कर सकते। देखते हैं एक बार।
मे बी वी कैन और नॉट
डिप्लॉयमेंट बैकअप को भी एक काम करते हैं
हम बस सबसे पहले हम क्या करते हैं गेट
करते हैं एक तो गेट करते हैं सेटअप डॉट
सेटअप अंडरs नोट्स इसको हम गेट कर लेते
हैं अपनी मशीन के ऊपर हमारी मशीन पे आ गई
उसके बाद हम क्या करते हैं डिप्लॉयमेंट के
ऊपर अब डिप्लॉयमेंट के अंदर क्या है हम
सीडी करके देखते हैं। सीडी एंड
डिप्लॉयमेंट
हिट एंटर किया। उसके बाद एलएस करते हैं।
यह रहा इसके अंदर भी कुछ है। लेफ्ट ओवर
कॉन्फिगx इसको भी हम गेट करते हैं। लेफ्ट
ओवर कॉन्फिगx
तो चलिए अभी हम चेक करते हैं एक बार हमारे
जो इस सर्वर पे क्या आया है? हमारी जो
मशीन है काली लinक्स पे हमें क्या देखने
को मिलेगा?
चलो एलएस करें तो हम यहां पर हमारे पास
क्या है सेटअप नोटxt और क्या था हमारा
लेफ्ट ऑलxt हम कैट करते हैं सेटअप डॉट
ओtxt हिट एंटर
नोवाटेक इंटरनल इंस्टॉलेशन नोट्स मेक
श्योर टू क्लीन अप लेफ्ट ओवर अनअटेंडेड
एक्सml फाइल्स
अनअटेंड एक्सml फाइल्स जैसे आपको पता है
चेक पाथ पैंथर डिक्शनरी एंड सिस्टम
प्रिपरेशन डिक्शनरी डू नॉट लीव पासवर्ड
इंसाइड कॉन्फ़िगरेशन फाइल्स और डिप्लॉयमेंट
शेयर्स।
ओके? उसमें क्या है? उसको चेक कर लेते
हैं। हमें क्या-क्या मिला यहां पे बताओ
अभी? अभी इंटेंशनली हमें बना हमने बनाया
है इसको। यह देखो
रिमाइंडर टू सेल्फ आफ्टर इमेजिंग डिलीट
दिस वन और दिस वन। एंड आल्सो रोटेट
टेंपरेरी डिप्लॉयमेंट अकाउंट वंस रोल आउट
इज कंप्लीट। इन दो चीजों से आपको क्या चीज
समझ में आ रही है? यह तो देखो मैंने
इंटेंशनली हिंट दिया है इसमें। बट
तो हमें क्या करना है अभी
कि भैया
हमें यह हमें इस फाइल को देखना है। मतलब
अनअटेंडेड फाइल डिलीट हुई नहीं हुई हमारा
टारगेट है। पता करना है क्योंकि इन्होंने
बोला हुआ है। इसमें हमें यहां से हिंट
हमें यही मिली है। पासवर्ड हमारे पास है।
ठीक है? पासवर्ड हमारे पास है। तो हम क्या
कर सकते हैं?
हमारे पास आरडीपी कनेक्शन है। तो आरडीपी
कनेक्शन के लिए हम क्या यूज कर सकते हैं?
एक्स फ्री आरडीपी एक्स
फ्री आरडीp3
अभी लेटेस्ट उसके बाद उसके जो कमांड रहती
है कमांड हम देख लेते हैं एक बार।
वेट वेट वेट एग्जैक्ट कमांड क्या थी
हमारी?
हां हफन
यू हफन यू उसके बाद आपका पासवर्ड
इंटरनल
सॉरी उसका यूजर नेम आपका पासवर्ड
आपका पासवर्ड है
विंटर
एस्केलेशन मार्क्स चेक करते हैं कि हम
एक्सेस ले पा रहे हैं नहीं ले पा रहे हैं।
देन ओनली हम देखते हैं फिर अभी
192.168.1.42
और हिट एंटर और हमें सक्सेसफुली एक्सेस
मिल गया।
हमने सक्सेसफुली एक्सेस मिल गया। अब बट यह
तो बहुत छोटा है। आपको कुछ दिखाई दे नहीं
रहा होगा। यह तो बहुत छोटा है। आपको कुछ
दिखाई दे नहीं रहा होगा। क्या करेंगे हम?
तो मैं एक काम करता हूं आप लोगों के लिए।
इसको यहां पर क्लोज करता हूं। और मेरे पास
विंडो मशीन है। तो मैं एक काम करता हूं।
अपने आरडीपी कनेक्शन से करते हैं हम।
रिमोट डेस्कटॉप कनेक्शन। और यहां पर हम
क्या करते हैं? चेंज। और यहां पर इस
एडमिनिस्ट्रेटर की जगह हम क्या रखते हैं?
अपना कौन सा इंटर्न हीट एंटर करते हैं।
कनेक्ट करने की कोशिश करते हैं। पासवर्ड
हमारे पास है
2024 और क्वेश्चन मार्क जिससे आपको ज्यादा
बड़ी स्क्रीन देखने को मिलेगी। यह देखो
मिल गया आपको एक्सेस मिल गया। तो अभी हम
देखते हैं हमें क्या-क्या देखने को मिल
रहा है। कनेक्शन मिल गया। तो हमें क्या
करना था? हमें तो एक्सेस मिल गया। अभी
हमें क्या करना है?
हमें क्या करना है? हमें वह चीज फाइंड आउट
करनी है। हमें फाइंड आउट करनी है। कहां पर
मिलेगी? देख लेते हैं। चलो कहां पर
मिलेगी? उसने बोला था कि सी विंडोज पैंथर
के अंदर। तो हम चेक कर लेते हैं क्योंकि
अभी तो हमें आरडीपी कनेक्शन मिला है और यह
रहा नाउ उसके बाद Windows और यहां पर हम
चेक कर लेते हैं ऐसे कोई चीजें है या
नहीं। यह हमें जीयूआई मिल गया इसलिए इजी
हो गया। सीएलआई के लिए हमें अलग से मेहनत
करनी पड़ती।
ठीक है? तो अभी जीयूआई मिल गया तो बहुत
इजी हो गया। सीएलआई के लिए हमें बहुत
ज़्यादा मेहनत करनी पड़ती। ओके? क्योंकि
गाइज़ मैं अभी सेशन को कंप्लीट करने के
चक्कर में हूं। तो इसलिए मैं आपको जीआई से
ही करवा रहा हूं। कोई दिक्कत नहीं।
अदरवाइज हम क्या कर सकते हैं? दूसरा एक और
चीज कर सकते हैं। चलो मैं एक काम करता हूं
आपको। इसमें ओपन करता हूं पावर सेल।
पावर सेल से दिखाता हूं आपको एक्सेस करना।
पावर सेल से इसका साइज बढ़ा देते हैं हम।
कहीं इसका साइज बढ़ा पाएंगे? हम इसको
देखते हैं प्रॉपर्टीज प्रॉपर्टीज और
ऑप्शन फोंट साइज हम रखते हैं एटलीस्ट 24
सो दैट ओके 24 हमने कर दिया चलो सही है 24
अभी आप लोगों के लिए
ओके दिखाई दे रहा है सबको
बिल्कुल तो एक कमांड होती है हमारी गेट हफ
कंटेंट
गेट कंटेंट
टी एन टी कंटेंट गेट कंटेंट से पहले हम
चेक भी तो कर सकते हैं ना
तो अगर हम प्रिलि चेक करते हैं पहले अपने
हु एम आई इंटर्न
हु
एम आई अंडरस्कोर
प्रिविलेज
इस पर नहीं सीएमडी पे काम करेगा कोई बात
नहीं तो हमें क्या करना था हमें प्रिलजेस
एस्केलेशन के लिए हमें
पहले आई विल वेट गाइस मैंने कहीं पे इसके
लिए कमांड मेंशन की थी आप लोगों के लिए
ताकि आप लोग हम एक और चीज थी हमें ये
कमांड यूज़ कर सकते हैं हम कि हां टेस्ट
टेस्ट पाथ
टेस्ट पाथ और हमें चेक करना है सी
डायरेक्टर के अंदर
सी डायरेक्टर के अंदर
क्या देखना है Windows यह कमांड है पावर
सेल की कमांड आपको बता रहा हूं जहां पर आप
चेक कर सकते हो यह अगर आपके पास एक्सेस
नहीं है तो पथर
और एक और चीज मैंने वह की है
अटेंडxml
ट्रू आ गया मतलब यह फाइल एक्सिस्ट करती
है। ट्रू आ गया मतलब यह फाइल एग्जिस्ट
करती है। आप क्या कर सकते हो? इसके आइटम
आप चेक भी कर सकते हो। इसके आइटम्स को देख
भी सकते हो। तो कैसे कर सकते हैं? तो आप
क्या कर सकते हो? कमांड होती है गेट
चाइल्ड आइटम
यह रहा सी
समझ में नहीं आ रहा क्या
विंडोज या बिल्कुल नई चीज लग रही है
पता चल गया यहां पर कि है अनअटेंडेड
एक्सml फाइल है यहां पर अनअटेंडेड एक्सml
फाइल यहां पर आपको देखने को मिल रही है
अनअटेंडेड एक्सेस फाइल आपको देखने को मिल
रही है। तो चलिए फिर कैसे कर सकते हैं?
कैसे कर सकते हैं? इसके इसको हमें फाइट
इसके कंटेंट को रीड करना पड़ेगा। इसके
कंटेंट को रीड करने के लिए एक तो नोटपड का
यूज कर सकते हैं। नोटपड उसके बाद
नोटपड उसके बाद हम यूज़ कर सकते हैं इसका
यू अनअटेंडेड एक्सML
एक्सML का भी यूज़ कर सकते हैं। लेकिन ये
टू क्रिएट न्यू ओके आई डोंट वांट टू
क्रिएट ए न्यू फाइल हम इसके लिए हम एक
कमांड यूज़ कर सकते हैं। सबसे बढ़िया मैं
आपको सारा ग्राफ सीएलआई के थ्रू दिखा रहा
हूं।
कंटेंट
हिट एंटर
फुल पाथ मेंशन करना पड़ेगा क्या
ओके आई एम सॉरी फॉर दैट सॉरी सॉरी सॉरी
और इसका पाथ क्या था यह रहा
पहले मैं इसको सीएलएस कर देता हूं।
अभी आपको दिखाता हूं।
ठीक एंटर तो यहां पे कुछ देखने को मिला
आपको यह देखो।
यह इंटेंसली बनाई गई है। वैसे आप ओरिजिनल
फाइल दोगे तो बहुत बड़ी होती है। बहुत कुछ
होता है। इसमें देखोगे सेटिंग पासवर्ड नेम
नेम ए ब्ल ब्ल ब्ल यूजर अकाउंट
एडमिनिस्ट्रेटर पासवर्ड। दिस इज द वैल्यू।
दिस इज़ द वैल्यू ऑफ़ एडमिनिस्ट्रेटर
पासवर्ड। द वैल्यू ऑफ़ ए एडमिनिस्ट्रेटर
पासवर्ड।
दिस इज़ द वैल्यू ऑफ़ एडमिनिस्ट्रेटर
पासवर्ड। आपकी बेस 64 में है। इसको आप
क्या कर सकते हो? डिकोड कर सकते हो। सबको
पता है। बेस 64 में डिकोड कर सकते हो।
कैसे करेंगे डिकोड करने के लिए बेस 64 में
डिकोड कैसे कर सकते हो और जो फ्लैग की मैं
बात कर रहा था वो फ्लैग आपका इसके अंदर है
विंडो सिस्टम 32 इसके डेस्क कहां पर फ्लैग
मिलने की बात थी वो हमारी वो वो फ्लैग
मिलता है हमें इसी के अंदर एक फ्लैग है जो
हमने सेटअप किया था बट वो आप आपको कभी ये
चैलेंज दूंगा तो माफ कर सकते हो अदरवाइज
तो हम एक काम करेंगे हमने इसको कॉपी किया
है और हम इसको मिनिमाइज करते हैं और इसको
को चलते हैं अपने काली नेक्स्ट के अंदर।
बहुत इजी है यार। इसके इतना सोचना नहीं है
इसमें।
इसको हम क्लोज कर देते हैं। और हम हमारी
एक जो कमांड होगी वो होगी हमारी कौन सी?
हमारी कमांड होगी एकको।
मैं इसको क्लियर कर देता हूं पहले।
एकको
कंट्रोल शिफ्ट वी
यह होगा। उसके बाद यह पाइप देन उसके बाद
हम यूज़ करेंगे बेस 60 बस सबसे आसान ही है।
बेस 64 हफन डी हफन डी नहीं हां हफन डी हिट
एंटर पासवर्ड 1 2 3 हमें मिल गया पासवर्ड
1 3 मिल गया हमें एडमिन का पासवर्ड
पासवर्ड 1 3
मिल गया हमें या नहीं मिला बताओ।
पासवर्ड 1 2 3 हमें मिल गया।
ओके और अगर आपको एक्सेस करके देखना है
इसको अभी देख लीजिए। पासवर्ड 1 2 3 आप
कैसे एक्सेस कर सकते हो। इस कनेक्शन को
क्लोज करते हैं। इस कनेक्शन को क्लोज करने
की जरूरत वैसे है नहीं है। हम इसको करते
हैं। कमांड लाइन चाहिए हमें तो पीs के
थ्रू कर सकते हैं। पीs के थ्रू मुझे कमांड
बताओ कैसे कर सकते हैं? बताओ कोई मुझे
बताएगा पीs एक्सक के थ्रू हम कैसे कर सकते
हैं? पीsx डॉट पाई है। उसके थ्रू हम कैसे
कर सकते हैं? बताओ
पूरी कमांड बताओ आप लोग मेरे को
तो ट्राई करते हैं।
पीएस एक्सक उसके बाद
हफन हफन
192.168.142
हफन
यू यूजर नेम हमारा एडमिनिस्ट्रेटर
एडमिनिस्ट्रेटर उसके बाद
एक मिनट हम उसमें देखते हैं कि कौन सा
अकाउंट उसने शो किया था। अभी थोड़ी देर
पहले देखा था हमने।
तो एक काम करते हैं व्हिच वन वाज़ दैट वन
दैट वन एडमिनिस्ट्रेटर हफन
पासवर्ड था हमारा क्या था कंट्रोल शिफ्ट
वी पासवर्ड 1 2 3 यही था आपका कमांड तो
चलिए उसके बाद पासवर्ड
पीsx
यही होना चाहिए।
कौन सी कमांड बताई यार आप लोगों ने?
नहीं पता आप लोगों को।
रिमोट कनेक्शन दिखा देता हूं आपको। इसको
क्लोज करता हूं। हमारे पास पासवर्ड मिल
गया था। हम इसको क्लोज करते हैं। इस
कनेक्शन को क्लोज करता हूं। उसके बाद मैं
अगेन आरडीपी कनेक्शन करता हूं। रिमोट
डेक्स कनेक्शन
एडमिनिस्ट्रेटर
एडमिनिस्ट्रेटर उसके बाद कनेक्ट पासवर्ड
मैं रखता हूं। कंट्रोल वी
ओके
नो नो नो नो नो नो ओके
यहां पर अभी शो गलत कर रहा है क्योंकि इट
मे बी
एनीथिंग एल्स x3 आरडीपी को हम यूज़ कर सकते
हैं फिर से
थ्री उसके बाद हफन
यू
एडमिनिस्ट्रेटर
और आई होप कि मुझे लग रहा है कि हमने कुछ
इसमें गलत कर दिया है। शायद मैं एक बार
ट्राई कर रहा हूं।
नो तो हमारे अकॉर्डिंग वो होना चाहिए
बढ़िया होगा।
ओके
क्या क्लास में लेट तो नहीं हो रहे गाइस?
आप लोग बस कर देते हैं। हो गया आपका हमारा
पासवर्ड हमें मिल गया बट अकाउंट यूजरनेम
हम गलत एंटर कर रहे हैं।
पहले स्क्रीन को क्लियर कर दें।
X3 आरडीपी थ्री। उसके बाद हम यूज करने
वाले हैं हफन
हमारा भी नहीं बार-बार मैं कमांड भूल जाता
हूं।
पासवर्ड
उसके बाद हो सकती है हमारी कमांड मे बी
नो मे बी समथिंग एल्स यूजरनेम के साथ
हमारी थोड़ी सी प्रॉब्लम हुई है लैब में
बट तरीका यही है आपको यहां पर
क्रेडेंशियल्स मिलेंगे और इन
क्रेडेंशियल्स को आप क्या करोगे यूज़ कर
सकते हो ओके गाइज़
यह सीटीएस जो मैंने सेटअप किया मे बी आई
थिंक मुझे कुछ और एडमिन नाम से किसी और
नाम से मैंने उसको सेटअप कर दिया है। बट
माय प्रॉब्लम इज दैट। तो यह था आपकी वो
फाइल फाइंड आउट करने की जो मैं आपको बताने
की कोशिश कर रहा था।
तो टॉपिक सबको क्लियर हुआ? सिटी फ्लैग्स
मैंने एक भी इसलिए शो नहीं किया।
हां मे बी
नॉट सो मच ग्रेट बट यू कैन से दैट इट इज ए
बिगिनियर प्लस बोल सकते हो नॉट ओनली बेसिक
लैब बिकॉज़ डिफेंडर ऑन था। मैं आपको दिखाऊं
तो दिखा सकता हूं। डिफेंडर ऑन था इसका मैं
स्क्रिप्ट के बेस पर। अभी मैं दिखाऊंगा
नहीं क्योंकि
तो चलिए फिर नेक्स्ट सेशन में मिलते हैं।
आज का सेशन यहीं पर एंड करते हैं। और एक
इंटरेस्टिंग लैब प्लस में लैब इजी होगी।
एक इंटरेस्टिंग टॉपिक मतलब टॉपिक यही
रहेगा। पास द हैश अटैक और मिमी कैट्स का
यूज़ देखते हैं और एक और लैब को सॉल्व करते
हैं और उसके बाद फिर हम फर्दर नए सेक्शन
या फदर नए टॉपिक्स के अंदर एंटर करेंगे।
ओके गाइस
अबकी बार मैं क्लास मे बी ट्यूसडे सैटरडे
संडे आई वा नो बिकॉज़ आई एम ट्रेवलिंग तो
आई एम नॉट अवेलेबल इन दिस सैटरडे संडे तो
मे बी मंडे और ट्यूसडे डेफिनेटली यू विल
गेट योर क्लास
कल तक आर्टिकल आई विल 100% ट्राई कि कल तक
मैं यह वाला आर्टिकल आपको प्रोवाइड कर
दूं।
ओके गाइस
चलिए फिर सेशन को एंड करते हैं।
सेशन को एंड करते हैं और नेक्स्ट सेशन में
मिलते हैं। ओके
बाय-ब एंड किसी को कोई डाउट है क्लास से
रिलेटेड तो बता दीजिए। अगर कोई डाउट नहीं
है तो भी बता दीजिए।
कोई डाउट नहीं है। सेशन को एंड करें फिर।
ये वैसे कहीं है नहीं क्योंकि मैंने यह
बताओ सबने एक काम एक चीज बताओ मेरे को कि
सभी ने Windows server 2019 इंस्टॉल किया
था जब मैंने आपको बताया था
मैं इसको स्क्रिप्ट दे सकता हूं। पावर सेल
स्क्रिप्ट प्रोवाइड कर सकता हूं। जस्ट
आपको क्या करना है? Windows सर्वर 2019 पे
इस स्क्रिप्ट को पावर सेल पे रन करना है
और यह सीट अप ऑटोमेटिकली सेटअप हो जाएगा।
मैं यह स्क्रिप्ट दे सकता हूं।
बट बात वही है कि स्क्रिप्ट मैं आपको आप
लोगों को प्रोवाइड कर दूंगा। तो फिर
स्क्रिप्ट देख के आप सशन ना कर लेना।
प्रैक्टिस के लिए स्क्रिप्ट का यूज़ कर
सकते हो। तो कितने लोगों ने Windows सर्वर
2019 को इंस्टॉल किया था? जल्दी से यस यस
बताइए।
ये किट मैं उसमें मेंशन कर दूंगा आर्टिकल
में और बताओ।
वन आदित्य ने किया था और
ओनली आदित्य
और किसी ने नहीं ओके जगतगुरु दो
सलमान तीन
हटा दिया तो अब आपकी आपने गलती कर दी अमन
शेख
तीन
ठीक है चार लोगों ने ना तो मैं एक काम
करता हूं स्क्रिप्ट शेयर कर दूंगा सेटअप
के लिए आप लोगों के पास वो आप उधर से जस्ट
कट कॉपी पेस्ट कर देना उसमें और स्क्रिप्ट
को रन कर देना उसके बाद टेस्टिंग कर लेना
सेम यह सिनेरियो क्रिएट होगा और सेम
सीटीएफ बिल्कुल एग्जैक्टली आपका सीटीएफ
क्रिएट हो जाएगा ओके गाइस तो चलिए फिर
बाय-बाय टेक केयर एंड सी यू फॉर नेक्स्ट
सेशन फिर मिलते हैं नेक्स्ट क्लास में
मंडे या ट्यूसडे को फिर से हमारे एक और
पारदा है अटैक के साथ ओके तो
चलिए फिर बाय-ब गुड नाइट एवरीवन एंड सी यू
फॉर नेक्स्ट सेशन।